so you can
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
perfect welcome back to the dope as
usual podcast i am thomas dobaziola
whatever you want to call me i am here
with marty o'neil what's up folks what
up we're back marty's hyped up today
guys
right before this episode i went to did
i just fall asleep
so sorry i'm on a different level of
marty today i get all hyped up because
we it's a production to put this thing
together and it's like running around
for 30 minutes look forward to just
relaxing and talking to you guys yeah i
was just
i may or may not have been doing
something i will wait till the
wait till the 10 minute nice guy clock
is over youtube very sorry about that um
what's up we're back season two and for
everyone out there i did not forget
about this pull-up i'm getting dms about
it
not forget about it episode 100 i'm
gonna do it don't worry it's closing in
it's closing in
believe me yeah yeah i know this is
about episode 70. you got about 30 weeks
trying we're still trying we're doing
good yeah oh yeah now you're doing it
trying fans might not know what you're
doing it's gonna happen i'm it's gonna
happen all right time to wake up here we
go everybody out there driving to work
from work wake up all right it's time to
roll your window down i get it i was
falling asleep i had to eat a bunch of
candy on the way back from her set the
other day just because i was passing out
in the middle of the day regular candy
or
oh yeah this is actual candy no not
edibles no way
i was eating regular candy i had to stay
awake so i feel you all right it's time
to wake up let's get straight into this
guys the first thing i want to do is
recap we always do this recap since the
last time we talked to you we have had
three new guests well not new but we've
had three more guests so one
goblin you guys always know that's a
it's awesome it's always going to be fun
fool's hilarious he actually just flew
in today i'm about to go um probably
chill with him tomorrow
uh he's doing no jumper today so that's
pretty awesome let's go yeah that's
pretty awesome so
then the next episode was my mom okay
you guys
always asked for my mom episode had to
bring her back because episode one i was
belligerently drunk i had to watch back
what we said because i don't even
remember
and then it's therapeutic yeah it was i
i don't know i was just talking [ __ ] to
my mom uh but the episode two all right
we made a little more dialed in i think
not so hey remember when you were
terrible
uh and for everyone out there that gets
mad at me doing that watch another show
uh
that's why it's my turn okay that's my
turn it's your time that was my time and
that's over i told my mom after that one
like don't worry if you ever come back
on the show
i'm done i'm done badgering you about
all this now we'll just talk about stuff
i respect her for coming in especially
the second time the second time all
right mom you said yes
remember that like oh gee why are you
asking me this stuff you said yeah you
agreed to go you agreed to come on the
show and i showed you the questions
[Music]
okay but anyway he's the only one i show
the questions to ever
ever no one else gets to see their
questions but he's just so you know i
was just on the phone with him 10
minutes before we started
what do you mean stupid oh oh come on
man what'd you post i posted a real
marty made of me and him we uh reviewed
a product the other day and it was
ridiculous so [ __ ] ridiculous it was
ridiculous
guys trying to get this fool to compute
words
and start to talk in between takes was
its own video
yeah
100 in between takes was the video
basically and also the last set of
guests jason ellis tony hawk guys
all right come on stop come on
all week marty and i hey everyone we're
gonna have tony hawk on the show this
week
still doesn't seem real it doesn't it
doesn't it's weird it's like it seems
like it was some sort of fluke or
something both useful what
it was a trip to me man i love the
contrast between the two of them too
it's perfect yin and yang yes
very conserved
a well-reserved man speaking when he
wants to speak and then we got jason i
as soon as i asked martian like
i've never really heard him talk too
much for the clips i think he sounds he
might sound like a pirate
yeah you kind of oh yeah yeah you sound
like what i think a pirate would sound
like jason l is very cool uh-huh super
cool guy i thought he was awesome how
about he has the the real deal this is
his real laugh
what is that last this is the vincent
price evil laugh sound effect it's his
real [ __ ] laugh
that was creepy yeah that's creepy
you're scared a lot
they're used to it from last night i
know but not that one yeah
um
but yeah that was amazing guys still
cannot believe it i uh
i have a picture
of me handing tony hawk push trees gear
in the push through his warehouse and
pluto for some reason that was almost
like as big as the episode to me that
was just an iconic [ __ ] picture you
got the fans on you're in the warehouse
he's all high and [ __ ]
he didn't smoke no there's no way he
left this place there's no way you're
getting out of here
knocks to death no
no way
he was done
so i thought that was a very big
accomplishment if you've been here since
early on in the episodes we've talked
about it many times you know one day
that'd be cool one day we're gonna get
them on here and it finally happened
thank you guys for making that possible
all the likes and all the comments and
all the numbers and everything going up
just helps us get bigger guests helps us
get the okay from their agent to go it's
okay go do you you can have the time go
do that show exactly that's that's all
it's really for so
shout out to jason too for saying oh i
get to pick who we're going on and i
said you guys are alright yeah thank you
so shout out to jason ells tony hawk
watch their show hawk vs wolf anywhere
you watch podcast anywhere you watch our
podcast go ahead and check it out
that being said marty what are we at
about 7 41
yes what are we at was 7 59 when you
said oh okay okay all right cool um on
to my next thing
before we start talking about crazy [ __ ]
so
cam surgery
marty oh my god everything's good yeah
update update us hey guys thank you so
much man
really i posted his little picture up on
instagram yesterday all the comments and
messages i got like it really
whenever something like that happens you
guys like really make the situation
legitimately feel a lot better just in
for me and my wife and sitting there
showing them all the comments and
everybody wishing them well talking
about how brave he is those [ __ ]
scary surgeries
we're talking about them going in
opening up his arm bone opening up a
window to his bone scraping out the
giant cyst that's inside that's
occupying his whole upper arm bone and
then filling it with bone
filler paper
concrete yeah and then sealing it shut
and then
he's he's back up you know fortnite
today fortnight yeah on his elbow
i don't know if you noticed that yeah no
no he's in a sling mm-hmm oh his weight
was on it yeah i don't know this was on
his shoulder he just got surgery on he
was in great shape what was he eating he
was eating something and he was saying
i'm like yo this kid's living it yeah
he's right he had a big ass cookie yeah
it was a big ass cookie
and he's talking [ __ ] before tonight but
yeah as of this morning he kind of
anesthesia kind of [ __ ] him up but it
was such a scary thing and like i said
it just made me so sad we did not expect
that diagnosis we went in there thinking
he had a fractured arm
and the doctor was basically like well
he's this is
serious he's gonna need a really major
surgery or he'll just never be able to
play sports again in life
and he's gonna have to be really protect
his arm and not be able to really do
much for the rest of his life and i just
in my mind went off to this butterfly
effect version of him
in college some [ __ ] like you know
just
off the path of life that he wants not
being able to do what he wants and just
this different person from how i always
like imagine his life's gonna turn out
for him so yeah i'm just glad that we
went through it it was scary we did it
he's feeling better he's gonna be back
in time for soccer season in the fall
thank you guys really appreciate that
super awesome
super sick how old is cam eight
he's uh yeah he just turned just turn it
right he's huge for me just hey yeah
yeah
well i want to update everybody on that
just because we're about to say horrible
things probably
i'm a buddy so
can i how's your son surgery here i tell
you the funny thing you said the other
day what i told you earlier oh yeah
all right so just to show how innocent
my kid is okay
i we were on the pine park podcast right
highly productive i had that going on my
phone so on youtube so we go and get in
the car my phone auto starts playing
youtube on the bluetooth when i get in
the car he looks on the screen now the
podcast must end it went right onto the
ericon video how to smoke weed with a
laser that's air con that's the title of
the video
and then cam looks up at the screen he
goes how does smoke weed with a laser
who's
weed that seems pure innocence
like a video game avatar characteristics
who is wheat how are you going to smoke
him with a laser
what
that's what he thought
killed somebody with a laser
that's some strange innocence man i was
just like i don't know bro i love that
yeah
so innocent that's awesome anyway let's
get into it it's 10 [ __ ] minutes it's
been 10 minutes
[ __ ]
good [ __ ] all right here we go
guys i'm gonna start oh hence the
mushroom push shroom's hat
i'm gonna start off this story with
something you guys have heard many times
before
but i'm gonna elaborate because i've
never ever ever wanted to talk about
online
or on
being recorded because i thought it was
insane
we've talked about the situation you
guys have heard the story i just talked
about it with raw g i've talked about it
in the story time where i took that huge
dose went into my room started floating
above my bed flying around my
neighborhood
we talked about all that stuff
every time i tell maurice you got to
tell the story nah not yet i've been
seeing all this disclosure [ __ ] about
aliens all this universe stuff all this
craziness all this
people are talking about stuff way more
than they used to and it makes me feel
like oh so people aren't gonna think i'm
insane
maybe i can talk about this guys this
happened to me eight years ago seven
years ago and i've never talked about on
story time
it's one i did never planned on talking
about fully because it scared the [ __ ]
out of me
but today i'm gonna tell you guys what
really happened in that night of the
mushroom trip where i said i was flying
around my room in my neighborhood
i'm going to tell you the whole thing
this is [ __ ] suspenseful this is
insane
so what really happened i've always i
never lie i just go you know crazy other
[ __ ] happened i was finding my room but
the night was intense that's how i end
it because i'm not lying
crazy other [ __ ] happened but that crazy
other [ __ ] took up 99 of that night i'm
only i've only given you guys one
percent
of what happened that night because i
just thought it was preposterous
and i want people like all right bro you
smoke a lot of weed and i just make up
stories like i'm just telling you what
happened to my head and what happened to
me
so i took the seven grams rosie took
seven grams like you've heard the story
go watch pink floyd every time i get to
the hospital scene go in the room
because it's too much for me i get
freaked out i go in the room
so seven grams in my room completely
pitch black because the merced pitch
black room so here's the story time
you've heard me talk about oh i like
felt like i was floating i blasted off
through my my my roof i looked down i
could see my body i was outer body
experience flying around my neighborhood
it was crazy
and that's where i stopped the story
every time because i don't want to talk
about it
i told marty a little bit about it but
now i'm going to tell you guys fully
what happened to me
i've talked to other i didn't tell
anybody me rosie told nobody for about a
year and a half then we told our other
friends that are very in psychedelics
they're like say what the [ __ ] did you
say and now they're telling like you had
a what a something something trip like
what are you talking about like you
broke through like what the [ __ ] does
that mean
so
i'm sitting there on my bed it's about
two hours in
guys i've never done this before on
mushrooms but this night i did it i
don't know what came over me i'm in the
pitch black i just start doing this
inhaling the slowest i've ever inhaled
in my life it felt like my lungs
expanded bigger than my chest could be
and then out
like a full minute in a full minute out
it just felt like my breathing like my
brain was starting to slow it was weird
i was just trying to breathe slow
because i was stripping
and the whole time i'm sweating i could
feel the sweat on my body just pouring
sweat like somebody's dumping water on
me
and then i told you i fly around my room
blah blah
the story ends this is what else
actually happened that night i've rosie
you know a couple more friends know they
told me i told my um maybe i told my mom
i don't know if not my mom's watching so
here we go
i'm up in the air i look down and it's
like a broadway play you know when
broadway play when the stage lighting
goes dim and it just spotlights like a
bed and they're having a scene you know
what i'm saying that's exactly what it
was it was a spotlight around my bed i
can see rosie i could see my own body
but it's a pitch black room
okay
no music going on just you can hear car
noises and maybe like the car headlights
past
through your window blinds if that
so i'm looking down i'm like wow
i must be [ __ ] gone i'm still aware
like yo these shrooms are crazy seven
grams what the [ __ ] i could see my body
i like that [ __ ] so i'm like i embraced
him like wow i wonder i moved my arm
and i could tell myself in my own eyes
move your arm and i could see my arm
move
on the bed
move my leg i could see my leg move like
yo this is [ __ ] crazy so what happens
is i look up
and it's like
you're not saying
run you're not saying move i just like
it's like you your intention of your
brain i can just tell like go faster go
faster i could it was the very weird
it's like i was a shark you know sharks
just
swim through the water that's how i felt
like i was going through the air just
it's like bleeding my head and my body
would move not like i was flapping my
arms or running the weirdest sensation
i've ever had i was moving at fast
speeds without moving my body
just intuitive yeah it was very weird so
one thing i don't get
why wasn't there stars
i start shooting straight into the sky
guys as high as i can possibly go
and i just start going like don't worry
man you're in your bed you're gonna be
fine that's my kids saying you're in
your bed you're in your bed you're in
your bed like you're fine you're not
gonna be fine you're not in space you're
in your bed
but i kept saying it so i would let it
keep going because there was a point
where i started getting light-headed
where i couldn't feel
like my body anymore and i just feel my
head and my like emotions of this [ __ ] i
mean i'm peeking crazy i can't feel my
body anyway
i skyrocket into the air and i'm in
pitch black and as i'm in the pitch
black
it stops like i'm in water
and i'm kind of like slightly floating
like this
i feel that i feel floating the scene
and get out
kinda i guess you could say the sunken
place yeah but i'm up i'm above
my bed like hundreds of miles in the sky
i mean i was just
and then i just stopped
and as i stop i do this i can feel my
body doing this i look i'm like
where's my [ __ ] arm at and i have no
body
like i'm looking down like but i can
feel myself but i don't see myself
and like there's nothing to touch
and and i don't care don't freak out
don't freak out you're on your bed i
kept having to say that [ __ ] to myself
and this is where i went
okay what's happening
i don't know about religions i don't
know about other cultures because i'm
[ __ ] ignorant
i'm in the sky and i see
i don't know how or where it came from
this big clay dial like a circle
with ridges on it and it has the
face that face like this
that the aztecs put on [ __ ]
like that crazy scary face with the
[ __ ] geographical shapes on his head
and this whole dial
like some [ __ ] you would see on the
floor
in someone's garden in arizona like a
[ __ ] thing and planted in the ground
something like that yeah and it's in
front of me and i'm looking at it and
it's got all these weird aztecs [ __ ]
i've seen and obviously in history in
the school like that's like some weird
mexico [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that
like that like the dials are the
calendar you know the calendar thing
that just kind of appears in the voice
oh and it was it was as big as a walmart
guys i'm looking at it and it's so
[ __ ] massive it's bigger than i can
look to i can't see the top of this
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] huge and i'm looking
at it like this is a badass mushroom
trip oh my god this is it because i know
where i'm at but i'm just like let it go
let it go let go and i'm looking at this
thing like what the [ __ ] and it starts
doing this
oh god
but the outer bezel like a watch is
staying still and the inside's turning
okay but it's got all these shapes on it
and it's red clay color okay you know
like red clay from like uh
native american [ __ ]
just like that color like bowls that
they pottery like pottery it's that
color you can see the texture of it it's
like that i'm in the pitch black of dark
and i'm like am i in space where are the
stars first thing i thought how come
there's no stars up here
i just saw a light but it wasn't the sun
i was very i wasn't questioning like
where's the light source coming from
like what the [ __ ] this dial sundial
doing in front of me so it's clicking
and i'm like what does this mean what
does this mean what does this mean i
started feeling like this thing was
pulling me closer i'm looking at and i
go
where's rosie
and like my brain went back to my head
and i went
oh [ __ ] what is she is she okay and i
just do this i don't dive i go
and like i can feel like
like i'm like go down get back down and
my body just starts or my
my vision starts going
hyperspace fast again and then i swear
to [ __ ] god i just felt this
and i'm in my bed like back in my bed
and i like
it's like i fell back into my body and i
and
like that marty
that's how i felt that's how i felt like
i went
and i bounced on the bed i went what the
[ __ ] and i checked on rosie and she's
just
all tripping the [ __ ] out so i'm like
you could say yeah yeah yeah i'm like
okay
okay
i stayed
and then i went
okay i gotta do this again that was the
first night only
i went i can't do that again that was
too far
i don't know how could you have shot
back up if you wanted to
i didn't know i sat there for hours just
stared in the black was tripping
seeing shapes weird [ __ ] going up above
my house looking at my body little weird
stuff
oh my nah that was too that was
out of my control
i couldn't feel myself anymore it was
just my
but it was cool it was scary it wasn't
scary so night number two i tell rosie
hey i explained to her what happened
she's like what the [ __ ]
i was talking to people and all this
other [ __ ] too but i was in space i go
oh [ __ ]
let's do it again how far in between the
next night oh sure next night i told her
i know you're not supposed to do it back
to back by mike seven again [ __ ] it we
took seven grams again each these crazy
long-ass mushrooms from this vegan and
mariposa and you're like this would be
craziest [ __ ] mushrooms and
everything you had like i don't give a
[ __ ]
they were he wasn't mine
i take seven she takes seven no pig
floyd no movies to go straight into the
room like all right tonight's the night
i'm gonna see what the [ __ ] i can do
we're on a mission yeah
and i'm in there for a couple hours
sweating just trying to breathe i'm
trying to mimic exactly like how
remember that if you guys watch
malcolm middle remember how almost balls
of 300 and he does the same weird steps
to get the 300 again the strikes that's
why i do the same steps like i was
breathing
real deep i closed my eyes i started
trimming i started feeling my chest
anyway and it started happening like oh
my god okay here we go and then guys i
don't know what happened but those
shrooms hit me harder than second night
than the first night
i
blasted the [ __ ] off through my house
was looking down controlling like
[ __ ] peter pan flying around my
neighborhood and whether or not i really
was or i was tripping kind of odd that i
know what my neighborhood looks like
from the top yeah you wouldn't have that
perspective i mean i could see backyards
i could see stuff in the back that's
like in dreams though your brain can
make things that you've never seen yeah
so that's what i was seeing as i'm
looking i'm like
yo is my brain that wild or am i really
in the sky like i was thinking like
couldn't tell the difference what is
this real but i knew i was on mushrooms
and i always kept saying you're right
there you're fine you're right dabbing
or smoking weed at all nothing
i was so [ __ ] seven grams you don't
need anything else
so
this is where story really takes off
this is a long story all right it's
gonna be a 45 minute clip let's go here
we go
so second night i'm sitting there same
exact thing rosie already told her what
happened to me and she's like well
that's [ __ ] crazy don't worry about
me i'm fine i'm like all right rosie if
i get too far i'm not coming back
because i'm not worried about you you
say you're fine you're going to be good
you're next to me
cool
i'm in the [ __ ] air again guys
it's not like i've read stuff about
people doing things or i watch sci-fi
[ __ ] enough to know about stuff i'm
biased yeah i just liked it and getting
[ __ ] up
so whatever the hell happened it's like
why did it happen
so i'm in the air again pitch black but
there's a light source but i can't see
it it's just
present does that make sense
it's like a street light is lit light me
up a little bit but i look up there's no
street light
it's just like
illuminated in this section of this
black yeah
i don't know how to put it uh-huh i
could feel my body
but nothing was there right
so
this is where i know someone's gonna go
what
you were in sector
nine five blah blah blah i know
somebody's gonna say some [ __ ] because i
don't know i think you were in it you
know my home was like what the [ __ ] did
you say and he started explaining it was
no
and that was like seven years ago
and i didn't i've still never talked
about till today so here we go
so
i feel i felt insane i thought i was
crazy and i didn't want to i don't tell
anybody that
because i'm like dude my mom
was kind of [ __ ] off when she was in
here
oh my grandma had mental [ __ ] i was like
am i [ __ ] insane
i didn't want to like oh god i am [ __ ]
but you're knowing you're tripping balls
off no but the [ __ ] that i'm seeing i'm
like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] oh
why is my head producing this i've never
seen this movie yeah
so
i'm in space or the black whatever the
[ __ ] you want to call there's no sundial
the void i'm just in pitch black not
water
i don't know what to call it but i'm
there and like a stage light really
small way down there i can see a circle
in my bed with two people on it can't
see my face can't see rosie's face i
know who they are because it's my
[ __ ] room does that make sense i know
home base is there if i really need to
get [ __ ] back all right like
beetlejuice when they open the door and
go what the [ __ ] that's my door home so
i know i'm okay
so
i don't know where guys i don't know how
long it's been up there i don't know if
there was a weight i couldn't tell you
the sounds i couldn't tell you the taste
of the air nothing i just know what i
i'm just telling you what i remember i'm
looking and out of nowhere
like a speck and this black starts
getting closer to me
real close then it gets closer to me and
it's like a huge surfboard
silver like silver surfer the comic book
guy
a huge surfboard made of like remember
quick uh
capri sun commercials and all the kids
were like gooey
silver surfer silver surfer like uh
alex mack is that is that a name uh
from anyway the girl that got toxic
waste on her and [ __ ] nick nicktoon
nickelodeon and she had powers i think
it's alex mack
anyway liquid metal like liquid metal
like terminator like that it looked like
terminator 2 when the guy turned back to
goo
t-1000
and it's coming up it's a surfboard it's
like a surfboard
shape but it's big
like size of a [ __ ] car
but it's shaped like a surfboard it's
flat and i'm looking at it makes no
noise i'm like oh
huh
the [ __ ] is that and as it gets closer
there's people sitting with it
just like this pretend this is the table
there are no [ __ ] chairs
and there's dudes sitting like they're
in chairs
on her right
and they're coming like
i'm not scared
i don't know why i'm not scared
i know this sounds [ __ ] and so like
people
let me explain to you okay
i'm over there surfboards coming into
this my view i see like the speck of
surfboard and then i'm like those are
people are those people
i'm just fascinated in the surfboard
thing i see the front of it i'm like the
back of it there's people on it
i don't know if they were there and they
just popped up but i didn't see him at
the beginning but as i got closer there
was people three people
one dude here
two guys sitting on that side i'm right
there and it's pulling up to me like i'm
at a bus stop
and the dude have i told you this whole
story no okay
i don't watch lord of the rings i don't
watch [ __ ] medieval times [ __ ] i
don't i don't give a [ __ ] i don't watch
harry potter
but the [ __ ] dude right here was a
big fat dude with red hair
but like long braided red hair like a
viking [ __ ] you see in cartoons and he
had this weird [ __ ] armor on
not like chain linked armor not knight
in shining armor armor like
medieval times with a [ __ ] crest on
his chest type [ __ ] yeah
and he has an accent and he talks like a
[ __ ] movie oh i was like oh
but he gets up but he stands up like he
has a chair under him it's the weirdest
[ __ ] they're not in chairs it's like all
their weights on the board
this sounds absurd sorry for everyone's
driving
this this [ __ ] oh god this story
he gets up and he runs over and hugs or
he runs over and i'm like oh and i know
his name couldn't tell you the name now
i knew him i said a name he said my name
thomas
hugged
the other dude stands up this guy's like
my height
other two dude stands up i cannot for
the life of me tell you what the do with
the darker hair look like i can't
it doesn't register
but the other guy have you ever seen uh
grounded for life the old fox show
grounded for life it's a the dad with
the with the short chopped hair he has
like a lord farquaad haircut from shrek
but red hair he looks like the dad from
grounded for life like just [ __ ] like
him but a stubble not a long beard the
guy with a darker outfit i can't
remember what the [ __ ] he looked like
this [ __ ] dude stands up and he's
like eight feet [ __ ] tall
but he's got like samurai armor on
but red and like
kind of like the dial
but red
like clay
color
but you could tell it's [ __ ] full of
metal and leathers and like straps he
looks like a medieval times fighter but
more samurai looking with like pieces of
wood on it
all red though
i look at him and i automatically know
him and the second i see him i'm like
overwhelmed like oh my god oh my god oh
my god i'm hugging all of them and i hug
them and they all just bend down and do
this [ __ ] like a kneel thing and i go
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] in my head
i'm normal guy over here i know i'm
thomas down here up here i have no
i and i'm just trying to walk the line
yeah so i don't go ah
and also i can make these fools think
that i know what they're talking about
because i want to know more yeah it's
like i'm in a video game like which path
would you like to choose i'm like yo
just remember the door's over there if i
want to go home if these fools are
acting weird
i know this sounds un unheard of this
sounds preposterous i know i'm on drugs
i understand that i'm just telling you
what happened to me this is how you're
supposed to do like people talk about
setting your intention before you do it
and like going into it with a purpose
trying to i just wanted to blast off and
see if i can go further than what i saw
what you're capable of and i just wanted
to like over you okay okay then i'm not
gonna worry about you and i knew she was
there that's all i knew yeah
so
i am like
where have you been guys i haven't seen
you like where have you been we've been
looking for you and i'm like i fell you
don't remember i fell and all of a
sudden i start remembering a memory that
i've never had of me falling off of this
table and landing in a [ __ ] body
guys i don't [ __ ] know i have i
couldn't tell you i couldn't tell you
[ __ ] i have no idea but i start
remembering
i did fall i did fall because i remember
me and these guys are sitting around the
table and i go
and i fall into this light and when i
follow this light i start remembering
thomas me
and up here i'm like oh yeah i fell down
and i that's right i did how long have i
been gone is the first thing i ask
and i don't remember what they said but
it's like i started remembering that's
right
i'm one of you guys why the [ __ ] am i
down there
that's what i remember and i go and in
my head over here i'm like yo what the
[ __ ] is happening i'm excited and
nervous
but over here i'm like that's right and
i start remembering
that's right we just travel around this
black [ __ ] void talking
and i fell off i remember falling
and i just started remembering [ __ ]
that's all i remember into a light and
then i just remember nothing after that
except like my normal life right uh-huh
so i'm like this is [ __ ] weird this
is crazy and i just stop them i go hey
there's something i want there's
somebody i want you to meet
i'm like this is my best friend ever and
they go
where are they at and i just guys i'm
standing on nothing
i'm not standing on anything you're just
existing i'm just thank you marty i'm
just existing there
but these guys have full bodies i'm
looking at them and like one guy's eight
like eight he's [ __ ] as big as the
roof man
but he's like so like
i haven't seen he's like hugging me and
[ __ ] and the dark-haired guy i don't
remember him even saying a word i don't
remember anything but i go there's
somebody watching to me and i just do
this
there's no arm but i in my head i'm like
reach your arm down and i just feel rosy
and i grab her arm i pick her up
and as i pick her up she she's next to
me and i can see rosie
and i'm like this is rosie wow and
they're like ah the guy the fat dude
with the beard picks her up like all
[ __ ] happy they all start hello i'm
so so i'm like
yes
like this is awesome i don't know what
this feeling is marty i have no idea
what this is but the the red hair the
chopped short the short haired guy with
the tall guy not the short guy with red
hair the tall guy with red hair justin
boy
basically justin boyd yes
he's like let's take a walk i'm like yes
please and i turn around and they're
just all rosy and those two dudes are
sitting at the table just like talking
it's like a [ __ ]
i i'm only like i'm saying i'm only
telling you what the [ __ ] i saw i'm not
trying to like embellish i'm just saying
things so if i'm like i don't know what
they said it's because i do not remember
i don't i'm not gonna make it up or say
i think blurry i was too blurry enough
for everyone out there that watches me
remember i'm on drugs please don't think
i'm [ __ ] insane this is just what
happened maybe it's a really really
really good mushroom trip maybe i
blasted off into some weird [ __ ]
it's been seven year eight years and i'm
finally talking about it all right so
don't make me feel like an [ __ ]
i start walking with this guy and i'm
not walking on anything i'm just walking
and i'm walking and i can feel my feet
touch but there's nothing down there's
nothing there there's no body
i'm walking
and then the void of black just turns
into this green country like china
i see a huge green mountain [ __ ] huge
mountain
in the distance another green ass
mountain to the right a [ __ ] huge
mountain but in the distance miles away
and the mountains in front of me
and i can hear like
talking not [ __ ] english
i hear obviously what i interpret as
chinese that i've heard in movies right
i look down marty
i must have been 25 30 feet above this
little village i look down and there is
a village below me
and there's people living lives this
lady has a [ __ ]
stick with two buckets of water and i
can see the water moving and spilling as
she's walking right old wooden [ __ ]
there's no i don't see cars i see some
cows i see [ __ ] goats
you know what take that back i don't
even know if it's goats i saw a white
animal that's all i remember like blurs
it could have been anything could have
been
i don't know
but i remember seeing big ass [ __ ]
cows or at least they'd look like cows
maybe they're like steers or bulls i
don't know what it was but i saw them
and they were like this wooden fence
and they're in this wooden fence
and i'm walking above them and i look at
him and he goes they can't see us
i'm like okay okay
i'm like what the [ __ ] is happening me
and him are just talking about the he
started talking about so since you've
been gone and it just fades out like a
movie i don't he's like so since you've
been gone
i don't hear what he's saying i'm just
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] i'm looking
at it guys i can hear people speaking
nobody's looking at me nobody's looking
up there's two [ __ ] people walking
on air
so i'm looking around i don't see cars i
see no tracks like what year is this
and i just see like a kid playing
i see chickens running around
and that's it
right and i look up and see this
mountain
like yo i've seen this mountain before
weird
the exact angle
right i'm like i don't get it
boom right back to the blackness and
everybody's at the table we just had to
talk and i didn't pay attention
maybe i should have paid attention to
the guy talking to me like since you've
been gone this is what we've been doing
you're like daydreaming i was just
looking at everybody because thomas is
taking over i don't want him to know
that regular guy's here and i'm like am
i walking above a [ __ ] village what
year is this how these people not seeing
me am i [ __ ] floating am i dead like
what the [ __ ] is that and then over here
space back i spaced out didn't listen to
what he had to say at all jesus christ i
was just looking and like yeah amazement
[ __ ] like i was like my chest i felt
like my chest was shaking but there was
no chest to touch
it makes sense yeah and no matter what i
can still do this and feel that my body
was moving on the bed
isn't that crazy i could still do this
i'd know that my body was on the bed i
could feel the sheets
but you're still present in that trip
moment
i'm not even close to being done uh-huh
we go back to the blackness
i see rosie
and i go let's go back
same thing happens i feel like i
plop on my bed
[ __ ] you guys all right let's just say
that first you guys okay first of all
[ __ ] you guys i'm not crazy just what
happened
i'm talking to rosie i'm talking to
rosie i wait i like not wake her up i'm
like hey bro zero zero zero jersey okay
okay okay i put a phone light on cause i
put my phone on i turn it off no do not
want that in there i turn the phone line
on because i don't want to put the
lights on and [ __ ] our [ __ ] up
and i turned it on and she's just
pouring sweat black ass eyes i'm like
rosie rosie all right so i realized i
explained to her what happened and then
she's and i'm like so what happened to
you she's like i don't know she starts
talking about this trip or she was
talking to something and she goes
and then you were there
and i started talking to this big guy
with red hair and he hugged me and i go
stop what did you say
i'm on my bed me and rosie are in our
room and poppy hills and merced go
what was he wearing she got like a
[ __ ] armor of like
i almost [ __ ] cried like what did you
just say to me and i go where are we
city's like in the black like blackness
go rosie shut the [ __ ] up rosie
and i started talking to my rosie are
you saying when i was talking to you you
could hear me when i was talking to
those guys up there she goes
i don't know it was a guy in red and
she's like
she started being like oh what the [ __ ]
i'm like i wanted to like i don't want
to destroy i don't want this i don't
like this i don't want to be here no
more if i could be so rude be sober i
don't want to do i don't want to be
around this it [ __ ] me up it scared me
like
what did you say
in like 20 minutes of talking about i'm
like rosie do you
do you think that's pot i'm more like is
this real
or did you just think
and i go do you remember the dad from
grounded for life [ __ ] just like the dad
with a short echo
shut the [ __ ] up she doesn't remember
the dark hair guy look like either
but from the shape of him he looked like
the guy from the mummy part one with the
long hair that helps
that helps brendan fraser that's what he
looked like his shape jake wolf
shorter hair j wolf that out [ __ ] that
outline yeah so guys remember we're like
probably four or five hours into this
i don't know what the [ __ ] going on
oh
and i tell rosie like hey
let's see if we could
you know
think about the same thing as me rosie's
frieza start dating we already started
dating i tell you guys that [ __ ] i
have lucid dreams very very vivid i can
change things i can do whatever i want i
can jump over a building it's [ __ ]
awesome it's like having an unlimited
video game in my sleep as i would love
to fall asleep as a kid but i was
insomniacs i never got to
when you really started dating we would
start going where do you want to go
that's one thing ask rosie marty like
where do you want to go tonight we would
be like what if we're like you know in a
cartoon wow i'm like i started thinking
about that
and we try to fall asleep because one
time we had the same dream because we
were talking about something
is this real or did we just happen to
think about that we did it every day for
like two years and one time it worked
you were the cartoon too or whatever it
was
so we used to say like where do you want
to go tonight i mean rosie used to say
that a lot so when this happened i'm
like
did we just sync up sync up
trips
i don't know
so like 20 minutes after talking about
she's telling me about my
slide back down slow back down you do
your thing and i'm like
oh f i am [ __ ] uh most of you guys see
me on the stream right here right two
grams imagine seven
the pitch black i am a different person
my eyes are gone i'm just thinking about
the earth
i'm not here there is no i'm not me it's
weird
but
night's not over guys i know it's a long
story i'm very sorry
we go back i lay down as i lay down this
is this is where it got [ __ ] weird
as we lay down
rosie starts thinking about something
i'm like all right rosie i'm gonna just
start doing my thing
and i don't know what it is guys like
deep deep deep slow breathing i felt
like i
had a key to going back
that makes sense
but this time was not good
i was like you know those movies were
like a
demon entity is coming to a town and
it's just
shh
and it's just a [ __ ] camera going
over the landscape
until it gets to a town that was my
vision i'm going over this [ __ ]
dirt
desert landscape fast as [ __ ] shh
and i don't know where i'm at and all of
a sudden i'm over this [ __ ] village
and i see a bunch i think i'm in africa
or ethiopia there's a bunch of little
tiny black kids all dying bro
like on the ground dying
like in an or like in a nursery
like all skinny as [ __ ] like the [ __ ]
you see on tv
and i remember like i'm like in a room
looking at all these babies in beds and
they're all like
i can see them all sucked up and i just
like start crying i remember i'm like
what the [ __ ]
and i can't leave
can't leave and all of a sudden i can
feel like a tear in real life
like hit my ear you know when a tear
gets in your ear as a kid you're all
pissed and just crying on your back it
went in my ear and it kind of like oh
and i was in my room
like it like snapped me out of my shakes
and went ah
i don't it sounds [ __ ] stupid but i
remember i'm looking i'm like
where am i
like what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ]
i don't want to see this i just remember
thinking like i don't want this
and like all these these little babies
were all they're a bald kids and they're
all so skinny with like little bloated
like little stomachs
you know what i'm saying like when you
see those sad ass pictures of babies
like dying of starvation that's what it
looked like to me
and i'm sitting there and i start
telling rosie i'm like i don't want to i
kind of want to do this anymore uh this
i like i'm all [ __ ] sad i'm all
distraught i'm like [ __ ] up i'm
tripping balls and pitch black telling
her what i just saw i'm all [ __ ] up
i'm all sad
and we're just talking about it i'm just
like
talking about [ __ ] we're doing now like
one day we're gonna get rich enough
we're gonna help and i'm like all
[ __ ] sad and [ __ ]
i mean rosie you're sitting there
and i put music on for the first time in
these trips i just put a
boom
dark side of the moon and put it on like
just leave it
just let it go
and just started playing it softly on
the phone in the other side of the room
so it wouldn't be too loud
and i could see rosie from like a
moonlight through the
blinds right so i could see like a sh
like enough to where i can make out her
eye i can see her nose shape
and i'm looking at rosie and i'm just
tripping letting like the
if you ever take seven grams it's very
intense anyway i'm all sad as [ __ ] all
the [ __ ] i just saw [ __ ] me up i don't
know where i was but it was like those
movies where i could sit in the
landscape
and all of a sudden i was just in this
town in a [ __ ] building
anyway
and i hope the government's not mad at
me for talking about this [ __ ] i'm just
talking about a mushroom trip guys i
ain't trying to change the world
please leave me alone i'm just i don't
want to talk about it that much but trip
report yeah i'm just tripping balls
right that's what the story is called i
trip balls
but i mean it's like people don't know
like is there a little
dimension you're able to tap into i
don't want to know or talk about it
openly and if i do you'll never hear
about it
because i don't want to get shot by the
government
um
all right
remember that me and rosie say that a
lot when the car we don't care
we're just talking out loud here
because my phone i've heard let's just
get on let's get on with it anyway
me rosie remember i'm just staring at i
could make out the
shape of her face and out of nowhere
this would mean rosie first started
dating and when me and rosie first
started dating it was random but like
random [ __ ] would like try to hit me
up and rosie knows better
dude i am
it's a [ __ ]
sport to me
telling [ __ ] to eat a dick not
literally eat a dick tell me just get
the [ __ ] out of here don't talk to me
it's a sport
because when i do i'm very polite and i
let them know the situation and when
they like well it doesn't have to be
like she doesn't have to and i'm like
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] i'm about to let you have it
[ __ ] and sometimes they they're some
it's it's gotten weird so that's when
that first started happening i know it
was on rosie's head and it was pissed
her off but she knows my path
you respond uh-huh i don't give a [ __ ]
you know what i do
i'm open book here i have a lock on my
phone here yeah
so she knows that but i know it was on
her mind
and
we're listening to song and i don't know
why i hear rosie like
is that girl i hear saying something
about the girl that hit me up all weird
i block the [ __ ] i hear it
but i don't hear it it's like i can see
the word
come out of her head
does that make sense this is 30 minutes
after the [ __ ]
sad baby [ __ ] and i'm all [ __ ] up i'm
just staring at her and she i'm just
looking at her like you know this is
insane i can't believe like this i can't
believe this is happening to me right
now
and i tell her like she's not gonna talk
to me i'm not talking to her and she
goes what i heard you
she was i didn't say anything
the [ __ ] did you just say uh-huh
and i had to think did i hear it
and i just laid there like
all right [ __ ]
so i'm just laying there on my side just
like
just tripping like i i i'm in the dark
whatever you think
it's like your eyes are projectors
there's nothing to trip out on so you're
only tripping on your thoughts
and i'm looking at rosie and i hear her
talk about it again
but this time i like it's not words that
i see flow out of her head it's like
like this feeling and it's like i can
hear it in my head uh-huh is that i
don't know if that makes sense like an
intention almost yeah like an intention
i can hear but i know what it said
does that make sense to you like hear
how she was feeling yeah but i could
know what the word she was saying
like i could heat it's like i could hear
her voice
but there was nothing to
say see that's what i don't talk about
it's just weird as [ __ ]
and i told her again like rosie i
[ __ ] heard she thomas i didn't say
[ __ ]
and i'm thinking am i tripping because
it's dark and i didn't see your mouth
move
or she tripping thinking she's only
talking inside and she's really talking
outside and i just can't see her mouth
move so i go
and i'm staring at him like is she is
she making me feel crazy right now
and i go rosie
think of a number
this is in our bedroom i'm on the left
side she's on the right side remember
everything bathroom right there my
[ __ ] hamper was right there i
remember all this [ __ ]
and i
it's like it's like i can hear
rosie
speak without her talking
five times in a row marty i told you
this part
five in a row guys
i told her to do two numbers back to
back i called him at the same time go at
the count of three second number seven
twelve fourteen and we both looked at
each other like get the
[ __ ] out of here and i'm looking at her
like rosie
whether or not i just guessed
why can why how is this happening
two colors in a row
five things back to back i might think
of something i went blue
she just looked to me
i'm like
no no do it again
brown
same time
we both looked at each other like
let's not trip out anymore and we didn't
eat mushrooms for five years
it scared us both so bad
i didn't know what that was
i could see and hear everything she was
saying without her speaking
i could i i know it sounds crazy like
you're high maybe you should put that
joint down shut the [ __ ] up i'm only
talking about what the [ __ ] happened
okay
what are we at like 45 minutes
yeah good
that's what happened
scared me we didn't tell anybody
me and rosie
sat there the whole rest of the night i
held her handshake on my hand and i
didn't do no blast-off [ __ ] i just sat
there and waited for the mushrooms to go
away i was so [ __ ] scared i was
nervous as hell
i looked at rosie she looked at me like
do you even want to talk about this
right now uh we didn't say we had the
mutual like no i don't talk about this
right now
sun came up
i ordered a breakfast burrito somewhere
i ate it and threw up some of it because
the mushrooms made me feel sick
i smoked so much weed
and then i fell asleep around 10 o'clock
what does so much weed me in that
instance like a half zip i mean rose
just rolled up giant joints and just
started going to town trying to go to
sleep
and then
we woke up in the midday we both fell
asleep on the couch i remember all this
woke up and we talked about it
and we i just want to reassure
that
what she said i heard what i heard she
said i don't think this sounds that
crazy because they talk about people
going to the jungle doing ayahuasca
ceremonies and tapping into the same
primal jungle [ __ ] like that [ __ ] [ __ ]
me up
i i don't know enough to even speak on
it but it doesn't seem that insane
every time you just don't every time you
trip i go i mean i've tripped before and
like
no
that's what i meant guys that's when i
always say you know some other crazy
should happen you know just tripping
balls
well that's pretty much the end of the
night that's how i sealed up mushroom
magic mushrooms in season one of story
time
that's the same story but i only told
you just a five percent yeah
because it makes me feel like i'm insane
i tell people i can hear what the [ __ ]
she was saying
without her saying it makes me feel like
i'm an [ __ ] yeah i'm not sure it
makes me feel like all right this ain't
heroes [ __ ]
i mean like no
that didn't happen and that's what i
said to myself for a long time like that
did not happen but i i know what
happened do you have any sort of
takeaway now like years later
i don't want to get back i don't want to
do it again that's why i haven't i guys
that's the last time i took big
mushrooms i don't take over like a gram
or two now
because i don't i have i don't have that
time yet so it sounds like the only part
of it that was kind of enjoyable where
you're kind of looking around like oh
this is cool there was a little bit of
that right but just like it was great
ten percent if it didn't scare me it
scared me because it was so real i know
what i saw
and i've seen movies and i thought they
were just movies i know what the [ __ ]
happened i could see
rosie's words
does that make sense it doesn't there's
no term for that so it [ __ ] me up
thinking like am i on some x-men [ __ ] i
don't want it i don't want this that's
kind of i want this how i really like to
think about life though like how people
think how people like
buy into a religion i like to think that
first of all i like to think that
there's no way you can understand that's
one of the rules like it's meant for you
not to be able to actually understand
what's going on you've got to accept
that off top
and then you know like
i like to think that i opted in
on some level on some soul level like i
opted in to come down and have this life
and
you know at some point i'm going to kind
of return to
where i originally started from i know
but i don't like the government being
mad at me i don't want i don't want to
talk about things that they don't want
other people to talk about i'll just
keep that [ __ ] to myself just talking
about the plot of avatar i mean thank
you steven spielberg
want to talk about avatar guys huge
movie of all time right no [ __ ] we're
talking about matrix
it scared me guys all i'm gonna say is
all the mushrooms so government leave it
at that i was on [ __ ] mushrooms i
don't know what the [ __ ] happened i
don't give a [ __ ] i'm not gonna explore
again
i'm chilling i'm chilling disclaimer not
to do the [ __ ]
no dude
i don't have that time
right i don't have that time anymore
that's really it i don't have the time
to contemplate three days of my life
because that [ __ ] [ __ ] me up for days
i was sitting there just
what did i just experience me and wrote
me and rosie both for like i said a year
and a half we finally told two of our
friends
because they are super into dmt blah
blah blah
and he started telling me about fourth
dimension beings and well what the [ __ ]
is what i'm talking about man
so
i don't want to get too into it if you
guys study that [ __ ] super cool
i am busy
if this is the matrix i'm taking
whatever pill makes you go back to work
okay all right government don't unplug
me i'm [ __ ] working i'm trying to
make my [ __ ] cool try to make this
avatar metal level really very cool
okay
so leave me the [ __ ] alone don't give me
the poor part and then take away the
cool part when i'm not poor you [ __ ]
[ __ ] just let me live my life
let me do my thing just want to buy a
house and drink grape juice
all right here we go
that was a very long story i'm sorry
but i finally told it i finally talked
about it and i never thought i would
honestly
but there's been so much [ __ ] in the
news i've been sending so many videos so
many movies about this kind of wild [ __ ]
that i feel like i don't i just didn't
want people to be like i'm not following
this phone anymore he is [ __ ] crazy
but it is a mushroom trip so maybe i was
just tripping who gives a [ __ ]
um
okay
another weird part
so
let's get on to this guys
i have a very good memory we've talked
about it extensively for years in story
time my memory is [ __ ]
bomb
bomb
i didn't know your brain can do [ __ ]
without you telling it
i didn't realize that your brain will do
stuff
to make sure you don't go crazy or
remember [ __ ] up [ __ ]
didn't know that
so
great memory about two years after my
grandma delores died i couldn't remember
anything about her weird got all i don't
know what happened
right i was super close closest person
in my life and maybe my brain did that
so i wouldn't be so [ __ ] up about it
don't know what happened great memory
super good i've done story times by my
uncle john a year later couldn't
remember how he talked for like a month
couldn't remember the sound of his voice
my brain just does weird [ __ ] to me
i mean i have
chilled with that man for about more
than half my life i couldn't remember
his voice for weeks
and i couldn't remember me and my
grandma what we used to do in the day
it's like my brain just put [ __ ] out so
i'm not sad about it i don't understand
it right
so
i'm not gonna get super into everything
but some [ __ ] happened to my family
recently right some [ __ ] happened
i'll talk about i want to talk about
we'll figure it out i don't know
let's leave with that some [ __ ] happen
in my family and my brother said
something my brother martin's like you
don't remember we talked about
all right separate separate event right
and then you guys already know the story
my dad used to be on drugs
and i remember everything i remember
everything about my dad being on drugs i
thought
so for everyone out there that
has these
memories they're like what the [ __ ] i
don't you're not alone all right i
didn't know that that [ __ ] was real
my brother said that you don't remember
having to find [ __ ] dad at spots i'm
like what are you taught me you're
dragging him out of those houses
and then just like a movie
pages of [ __ ] memories started coming
back i forgot about all that [ __ ]
rose he said it i told rosie because
what do you mean never told me that i'm
like rosie
i forgot
my brain
peter pan i went out of neverland is
what happened
and all my memories went away because i
became an adult that's some peter pan
[ __ ]
i forgot when my brother said you
remember having to chase dad down to
find him i forgot about these times guys
i used to have to find my dad at meth
houses and find i used to have to find
his ass to try to bring his ass home
i forgot all right i went i did that for
[ __ ]
years i forgot about all the talks and
all the times i'd have to try to talk
his ass down
and
he'd be shit-facing on crank and [ __ ]
trunk and
my dad's
super nice guy super like emotional and
sensitive and [ __ ] so he's all [ __ ] up
like his emotions come out
and like
it's not fun it's sad right
so some [ __ ] having my family and then
my brother brought that up but i'm like
whoa i forgot about that so my memory
just it unlocked some [ __ ] this past
weekend
and i remembered so
much stuff
shitty shitty stuff
that i forgot about comp i mean i have
that memory is on point i thought
and yeah i forgot i completely forgot
about like that five-year part of my not
even i forgot about that first 18 years
of my life completely forgot about it
i remember going to that piece of [ __ ]
johnny's house looking for my dad i
remember all the times me telling that
guy johnny i hate you stop doing drugs
with my dad and [ __ ] and he would still
show up even though i see the look on
his face like [ __ ]
like he knew he was wrong if like a 12
year old is saying please stop doing
drugs with my dad
he knows he's wrong i remember his face
and i saw him in the store when i was
older i remember i just i just wanted to
kill his ass but he was sober i was like
you know what [ __ ] he's sober but i
remember all these pieces of [ __ ]
friends my dad had and remembering like
having my mom drive me around to see if
i could spot one of their cars so i
could find out where my dad is because
it's been a week
[ __ ] like that i forgot about all that
[ __ ]
completely forgot about it guys and it
all just came back to me all weird
it was so weird
and then my sister
we're at my dad's house and my sister i
said something she's like what happened
to your photographic memory you [ __ ]
[ __ ] and go [ __ ] you full i know what
i'm talking about my memory is great she
goes oh so you don't remember that go no
what the [ __ ]
and i just stopped
she's like i'm like she's like you had
your own room a [ __ ] i didn't have my
[ __ ] own room what the [ __ ] are you
talking about she goes dude when we
lived all night on behind right and you
had your own room go straight
no i [ __ ] and i stopped and went wait
i remember when we moved in there i was
13. my mom's all he's a boy
he should not be in the same room as you
know a girl in high school so my mom
made my sister share her room with her
and she was like i slept on the couch
blah blah
i forgot
i was like shrine your [ __ ] oh and it
unlocked all these [ __ ] memories
about living at that house and all the
[ __ ] that used to happen
i forgot about all of it it's so weird i
forgot about year chunks ears
and my sister said i go
what
and i flash back like all the memories i
searched the house and i go wait there's
only three doors bathroom two bedrooms
that means she's right i forgot i had my
own room one time
and i went
oh that's why you hated me
because i had my own [ __ ] room
and she had to share with my mom because
they were girls i slept on the couch
well you had a bed with my mom first off
you [ __ ] [ __ ] i shared a bed with my
mom for [ __ ] five years of my life so
i get it but
it made me think like oh damn sharing
that sucks dan you had to go through
that because when i was 16 through 18 i
slept on the couch because my aunt
pepper my uncle john lived with my
grandpa on 6th street and they were
always arguing so they were like i don't
know if they're going to get separated
at the time they they made up they they
were happy right right
but my uncle john took one where my aunt
took one room and i just slept on the
couch for like two years i never think
this couch is so small i can barely fit
and i'm just sleeping on this [ __ ] for
two years because you guys can't work
out your marriage and i felt like so
played
and then when shereen said i'm like oh
you've been played too
so it's not it's just all on me because
this whole time like [ __ ] you never had
to sit in the couch for two years but yo
yeah you did
i forgot don't know how but i did like
my memory just erased that part
anyway i only brought that up because i
thought my memory was so on point and i
forgot about things huge chunks
so that's what i'm bringing back all
right my memory came back this weekend
it was weird as [ __ ] my memory of all
the bad [ __ ] came back this weekend
that i thought i knew all the best you
never manually archived it away and i
didn't [ __ ] press archive on [ __ ]
uh-huh it just happened
[ __ ]
i'm thinking about all the bad [ __ ] with
my dad now like wow
that's right
weird
i forgot people
might not really know that you went
through all that [ __ ] you see kids go
through an intervention oh my god yeah
i've been my dad's intervention twice i
forgot about you all those narcotics
anonymous meetings all this heroin
addicts next to me i forgot
completely
i don't know how but i my brain just
erased it all
until my brother said you don't remember
dragging dad out go
[ __ ] you oh
yeah
it's like when you watch a movie from
when you're a kid you go oh my god i
remember this movie and i went what the
[ __ ]
yes i do remember that oh i remember
that [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that
very odd very weird but
let's move on to some positivity real
quick
currently in this other room my little
brother rocco is setting up my pc
for twitch got everything set up got the
gaming desk got the monitors got the
[ __ ] camera got my other camera
coming got the lights got everything
he's doing stream labs doing all my [ __ ]
all my downloading all my games
everything right now
the reason i bring up rocco if you've
been on ribbon dip lately all right all
right so check this out from 12 from 11
my little brother told me about this
brand called rip and dip and whether you
like the brand or not stuck my dick i
don't give a [ __ ] my little brother
loves it right
he loves it he loves it loves it
i buy since 11 right he's about turn 18
since 11 or 12. all over his room his
whole room rip and dip stickers ribbon
he just loves the brand he's just he
likes it he's a little kid he loved it
he's light switch light switch
everything his posters his clothes his
drawings that he draws all ribbon dip
influenced stuff since he was a kid he
just loves the brand so now he's 18.
shout out to ratchet man until regiment
i want to go buy my brother some [ __ ] on
fairfax ratchet man knows the owner so
we go in there and the owner's there
greets us like yo pick out some [ __ ] so
i buy my brother's stuff and he gives me
a huge ass discount i wasn't trying to
get a discount i just wanted to get my
brother some stuff and go hey rip it up
saying come in because i wanted to film
it for the ten thousand dollar shopping
spree that day yeah um
and my brother i told him when he was
like 15. you're gonna be a [ __ ] model
bro you look so cool and you're a cool
[ __ ]
you can you can do this you look cool
that's why he on push trees that tall
kid with the curly hair that's my
brother he's our model right
so he after we left that day for a ten
thousand dollar shopping spree i posted
my brothers were taking pictures and the
owner of ribbon did put up ratchet man i
was like yo who's that guy you brought
in the tall skinny kid would he shoot
some pictures for me so
he should i did my brother on the 420
drop that was him all the 420 pictures
that was my little brother for ribbon
dip
just irony just randomly right i just
happened to be the 420 drop it wasn't on
purpose
so two weeks ago my brother did like the
catalog shot and all the [ __ ] came out
so if you're on rip and dip and you
click the shirts that's my brother it's
very cool the post the picture the
videos they posted
in the montages had my brother looking
all sick and the overalls it like
it was just very cool man that
[ __ ] graduates in like two weeks
he turns 18 in three weeks and he's
gonna move down here so that was very
cool just want to throw that out there
let's go pretty [ __ ] awesome um
okay
you ready
what's up guys just taking a minute to
talk about our sponsor for the year and
this is miller lite and i've said it
many times you guys already know
drinking middle light reminds me of
summer nights night times chilling
michael john just having fun for those
yeah at work or at school right now i'm
very sorry but remember that feeling of
just being outside it's kind of hot and
the breeze hits you and you're drinking
a beer that is the nostalgia that i like
to feel that's summer nights to me and
it rem i can taste the miller light so
right now if you go to
www.millerlight.com forward slash ola
that's going to bring you to a landing
page and that's going to show you every
single place in your area that delivers
beer to your house or if you don't want
to go to meleewite.com just go to any
store on earth that sells beer we say it
every time guys 96 calories 3.2 grams of
carbs for every 12 ounce beer as always
guys celebrate responsibly from the
miller brewing company in milwaukee
wisconsin i've said it before i'm gonna
say it again miller lite is the light
beer for people that like beer that
taste like beer once again before we get
here go to millerlite.com forward slash
yola that's gonna bring you to the
landing page shows you all the places
that deliver beer like i said if not go
to any store go to any single store and
pick up a case
so for marty and i the dopes usual
podcast thank you so much for watching
it's miller time
hey what's up guys just want to take
this quick moment to talk about one of
our sponsors and this is seatgeek if you
haven't heard about seatgeek let me
break it down really quick this is a
ticketing app you can go there and buy
the lowest price tickets for the events
that you want to see anything from ufc
to baseball to football to your favorite
concert and also it's the best price on
the internet it's as easy as that go
right now to the app store download see
geek that app go type in dope as usual
on the checkout anything you buy any
concert doesn't matter what sport it is
doesn't matter what day it is use our
code dope as usual and you get twenty
dollars off any ticket if you watch the
dopa zolo channel you saw the vlog where
rosie and i were in vegas we're in santa
cruz we're in san francisco we started
off that vlog at the raiders game how do
you think we got those tickets and how
did they get those tickets as we're
pulling up we got on seatgeek we got em
and we got great seats if you watched
our video you know where we sat we got
those very cheap so let's go on the app
find your seat find your ticket the
green dot means this is a great deal
this is for you you get to pick and
adjust your price anything any event
anytime so once again guys you code dope
as usual at checkout just go to the app
store download see geek once you're in
there use our code you get 20 off of any
single ticket you buy as always thank
you for supporting the brands that
support us back to the episode
all right on to my next subject bringing
back this segment of what's good i've
found some cool ass [ __ ] news
if you don't know what the section of
what's good this is season one and not a
lot of cool shit's been happening lately
it's all bad so that's why what's good
hasn't been here that often but we
brought it back i found some very very
very
awesome [ __ ] let's get started
guys if you watch the office like i do
you know what scott's tots episode is
michael scott
went to a third grade school and said
i'm gonna pay for all your college
tuition because he thought he'd be a
millionaire by that time because he has
time for them to grow up and he gets
make money
then he goes the day of graduation to
tell him that he can't do it
and breaks all their hearts right in the
most comedic way possible marty by the
way i love that all right so real life
scott's tots but in a good way marty can
you go to the notes real quick
are you ready for what the [ __ ] just
happened
otis college of art and design okay this
man named evan spiegel he's the
co-founder of snapchat
and went to that college he's an alumni
of that school he's giving a [ __ ]
speech at the graduation of this college
marty he's giving a speech about how he
went to the school and at the end he
goes by the way i'm making the single
largest donation and paying everyone's
tuition off everyone's student loans
everything
of the whole graduating class
are you [ __ ] kidding me
what a badass damn
that's amazing i love that's gonna be so
much money
nothing to him oh yeah it's true but to
these students that went all right i
graduated i started paying this loan off
that's everything that's you're you're
not dating you're like whole for 15
years changed their whole life
oh man when i saw i couldn't [ __ ]
make more of me use snapchat stop
deleting me snapchat but it makes me
want to use snapchat more yeah because
it's just that how
[ __ ] epic like
i'm surprised i didn't hear about that
it's [ __ ] up you don't hear you don't
hear about it because you have to find
on other news sources because they don't
want you to know the good stuff
but that happened all right shout out to
the [ __ ] what's his name evan
spiegel shout out to you all right i
click i put that link in there marty
cause if you want you can check it out
it's just all these [ __ ] people going
nuts yeah i mean
they're going nuts i can't imagine
because i mean it's like i'm still
paying my [ __ ] [ __ ] off from oh 405
just i'm not even touching the [ __ ]
principal
sorry [ __ ] just pay it the rest of your
life
even though you didn't get a degree or
nothing
so bad dude it's so bad but yeah how
epic is that so that's part that's the
first step of what's good i just wanted
to include that because it's too [ __ ]
cool this next part's a little more wild
but wow
so martin you've heard of sids yeah for
kids right that's horrifying sudden
infant death syndrome it's really sad
it's when the kid just doesn't breathe
and you wake up and to get your child
from the crib and they're dead
it's [ __ ] horrible right the worst
thing and they don't know why
it just happens under two years old
they're susceptible to that [ __ ] i don't
know why it happens they don't
understand
it's been happening since earth started
it just happened still happens to this
day probably happened today it's that
bad
it's not super common but it's enough to
where people oh i know what sids is
so
these scientists marty have found out
the reason behind sits and are currently
working on something to fix it
you are a research [ __ ] bad god
damn are you ready
are you ready yeah certain babies have a
lower enzyme uh
production there's an enzyme in your
body that wakes you up when you're not
breathing that's why you can live when
you sleep and you wake up
people with sleep apnea don't breathe
but they start breathing again
because the enzyme in their body tells
them yo you have no [ __ ] air
open your eyes wake the [ __ ] up that's
the enzyme some kids are born with low
levels of it and that's it
wow
their body doesn't tell them to wake up
because that enzyme's not producing fast
enough so when they stop breathing in
their sleep
they just don't start breathing again
that's it
it's nothing crazy it's not the parent's
fault all these people think they're bad
parents like your kid oh yeah right yeah
right you know how many people did it
have to happen to to where they go
is this a thing
you know what i mean like yeah people or
kids are dying for nothing
so six there's no explanation no
explanation until 2022 me
so they found it the doctors are now
working on an enzyme that you could test
your baby to see if he has or he or she
has a low enough level that you should
be scared and if so they can give them
something to keep it high that's it
they're [ __ ] fascinating
that's terrifying it's the scariest [ __ ]
you could ever imagine like hey we're
good everything's right we're doing good
dead
heated
oh you can't blame nobody you just have
to deal with it
yeah so shout out to these [ __ ]
scientists out here
literally saving lives
so thank you
thanks mr scientist i want you to mop
the rest of this [ __ ] up i know it ain't
your job
um
yeah so there it is and if you guys
think i'm talking about dead baby
mopping no it's not it's a half-baked
reference all right in case you're like
that was offensive then [ __ ] you it's
half baked
um we got to get a couple chapels in for
this [ __ ] episode
yeah every episode every solo episode
this solo has felt so
unfunny and serious it's not intense
yeah i feel like it's just not fun or
funny and it's just serious
that's okay okay intense is okay okay
this is real [ __ ] okay people appreciate
you putting yourself out there let's all
right let's switch it up then yeah and
let's talk about this real quick
from the dopey shop we talked about in
the last episode
guys
you guys know we get deleted and all
that stuff i get to lead off instagram
all the time blah blah blah
even if we keep getting deleted what a
win
john claudio and i just did an interview
about the dopist it was mainly about how
i started everything and then how we
started dopa shop and where it is today
because we're only five months in we're
crushing it right
so we did an interview
a light interview it's a light interview
and who did we do that interview with
forbes [ __ ] magazine
[Music]
this face high with smoke around it it's
going to be in forbes magazine guys
let's go
yeah
now that's [ __ ] our lights are called
dmx
that's a term in lighting oh yeah that's
awesome sorry i just looked up like dmx
oh man i'm slipping not having him on
the block
why don't you put like his marker ride
or die on the back yeah that'd be kind
of hard okay sorry back to what i'm
saying [ __ ] forbes
all right and when they asked the firs
one of the things they go hey you can
edit this right i can just talk normally
goes don't worry man i go oh by the way
uh the guy writing the thing watches our
videos he goes you taught me how to uh
what do you say
oh that was the photographer he goes you
taught me how to dab and quarantine i
met a photographer i was filming with
for something i had a dab how to take a
dab so you taught me how to take a dab
during quarantine go oh [ __ ] i'm like
nice but the dude for four was like oh
yeah you i've seen your review you did a
view from my friend turns out we have a
mutual friend and then he goes you're
the guy with the 40 gram joint huh yeah
because i saw that video i saw this guy
just smoking a ridiculous amount of weed
like years ago my house was like [ __ ]
four years ago
anyway i thought that was very cool that
the [ __ ] guy writing the article was
already hyped
and uh
hell yeah we started off with like i
used to just sell a lot of packs that's
how i started up the article you know i
used to sell a lot of packs
i just kept thinking i can't believe i'm
doing a forbes interview right now did
he understand was he like did you have a
amazon e-commerce so he's in the week
he's heavily into this
um
but yeah i thought that was [ __ ]
crazy we just did the interview for
forbes it should be coming out in june
taking the [ __ ] pretty far right now
we're just getting kicking off
insane is that tropical that's a
tropical sunrise i could taste it
um
yeah
so i just want to throw that out there
[ __ ] forbes magazine
it wasn't that long ago it wasn't that
long ago two weeks ago i'm still getting
deleted and that forbes is out here can
we do an interview with you
that instagram is like you [ __ ] you in
your
smile pictures and i want to acknowledge
that you didn't go and try to
my advice was put instagram on [ __ ]
blast in that article and you didn't i
don't think no i didn't you could have
it could have but you weren't a whiny
little baby about it like i would about
it
they they could just at this point i'm
like you know on instagram
[ __ ] you i don't give a [ __ ] twitter
likes me uh i'll call stay still
yesterday i hit 10k today for the 41st
time wait
for the 410th time
does that make sense
no no 41st wow my math is just so dumb i
was doing it as hundreds uh-huh i'm cool
um drug math uh-huh oh you're doing
followers if i said i actually would
have had it on the dot
[ __ ] [ __ ]
uh so yeah forbes interview [ __ ] new
instagram just a 10k because i just got
deleted again
thanks
um
all right on to something [ __ ]
hilarious all right
let's start off with something not too
hilarious there's some tweakers in
merced you guys know that [ __ ] my
grandma
lives we talked about this my grandma's
in the country remember that i stole my
grandma's car drove up in the country
drove down the road or running from the
cops we had to ride run down the road
the [ __ ] cop with the gun in my
[ __ ] mouth not really my mouth but in
my [ __ ] face
that house in the cuts of merced
so if you remember said you smelled
smoke the other day it was my grandma's
these [ __ ] tweakers that are like two
acres out they're tweaking we know them
tweakers they've been tweakers since my
dad was a little kid their kids are
tweakers and their kids are tweakers
your children's children's children i
just watched hook the other day
and your children's children will be
hooked on men
and their children's children
yeah first freddie
now it's captain hook
we're on to something here okay sorry
we're onto something back to this
horribleness these [ __ ] tweakers set
a fire
in the field because they were bonfire
or something and it caught the whole
field on fire what's next that field my
grandma's field it cut my grandma's
entire property on fire
all of the field all the other field the
front of my grandma's house my grandma
is in the country so there's a propane
tank outside that leads the gas lines
into the house
it was eight feet from the propane tank
when the firefighters got there and
stopped it my cut my uncle carlos had
just cut the grass a couple days before
and if he didn't it would have caught
the whole house all gone my grandma's
house exploded exploded too [ __ ]
gaslight went straight to the house
would have [ __ ] killed whoever was in
the [ __ ] living room and the kitchen
and the fire department got there
stopped at all
everything
crazy my grandpa's lived there for like
50 years
and his whole life work almost went up
in flames right
which is insane to me i was like i got a
picture of my cousin go
what grandma's [ __ ] house i was
tripping man i grew up there i'm like oh
my god at least i saved the house
everything's fine just to burn fields
totally cool they don't grow [ __ ]
cool
you guys have heard stories of my
grandpa greg
my grandpa my mexicans my dad's at my
grandpa greg is an evil man not anymore
he takes antipsychotic medicine now to
not be full of rage
this is a real statement
he's a he's a madman
i'm gonna get into it he's a man man you
guys have heard my grandpa's not a great
person
cool guy now not a great person from the
jungle they go from the jungle you gotta
keep that at five or four
he's gonna be stern yeah
um
so you know my grandma i'm not gonna go
too into it my grandpa is you know
typical old school mexican don't talk
i'll punch you in the face
how old is he like
is 89 my grandpa my grandma's 66. so
that means he was born
he was 30 she was 14 when they got
married if you're 89. you were born like
he was born in 1931.
that seems so long ago
33 sorry 1933 yeah oh my god
yeah um
long story it was the 60s 50s whatever
it was my grandma got taken right
now we're here but
i'm a product of
the evil i know i am very sorry
and uh
long story short my grandpa's
ruled my grandma's life since they since
she was a kid
until now
she's been a mom since 15.
did your grandma have family in out in
california
at all she was just a girl in mexico
long story i don't know if we'll get
demonetized and age restricted for it so
i won't tell that story yet
horrible [ __ ]
my grandpa's basically had my grandma
like this
since she was 14 right
so my grandpa is a tough man works his
ass off he's nice now he's a reasonable
person in the past 15 years now
right
he's a monster
but about four months ago my grandpa
passed out in the driveway and i had
like a mini stroke
my grandpa was lifting hay bales at 88
throwing him in his truck
doing [ __ ] like my grandpa he always
says if you stop working you die that's
why when he retired he just started
working on his properties
he retired at 80. you don't give a [ __ ]
he's just working
so my grandma is now
holding the steering wheel
my grandpa's kind of feeble
so in my head i like to imagine her
going shut the [ __ ] up it just i know
it's mean but i just want like that
the color purple like i got the razor
now some handmade's some [ __ ] right
that's how i think of it my grandpa's a
nice guy now and i wouldn't i wouldn't
be like yeah get him i wouldn't do that
but if she did i'd be like i understand
why you did what you did my grandma
didn't do nothing too she's not beating
this after nothing no hell no but i'm
saying that fire happened
i gave you the backstory my grandma
grandpa
that fire happened i've been planning
with him because my grandma's going on
her first vacation
in her life
she's only been in mexico and back
acapulco where she's from
my grandma's going to
switzerland germany italy rome argentina
and two other countries my grandma and
she told me how much you get this for
grandma and me my sister called after we
after we left our house like make sure
this place is real they're gonna [ __ ]
kidnap grandma grandpa like this is too
cheap nah they're gonna be like or even
heart organ harvesters and [ __ ] no hell
no we gotta make sure who the [ __ ] i was
legitimately concerned four bands
a person to go across the world grandma
not a lot
grandma i'm like don't trust them
that's how i felt i will do the research
i'm like okay this is fine
anyway i picked um up from the train
station down here got him a hotel in la
i passed her by the [ __ ] billboard
which is insane my grandma's song was
like oh wow
she didn't it was weird and i'm brown so
that's a crazy ass thing to say like my
grandma was cool she was like wow good
job
i was like wow she could have been
mortified i know but i went grandma look
it's legal and she goes oh my grandpa oh
nice he didn't see [ __ ] you couldn't see
no glasses on me oh no nice
i was like oh good
yeah
okay and uh
i'm gonna take them to their plane done
ready this is why i brought all of this
up god i tell stories so long
my grandpa come here [ __ ] her
whole life right my grandpa two months
ago
falls down now he's like help me help me
get in the car you drive because i can't
see that well he's starting to forget
[ __ ]
he's starting to repeat himself
because he has a vein blockage in his
neck and his brain and they say we can
fix his surgery he goes no
i'll fix it myself
he's just been eating healthier and work
and like working like it's gonna fix a
vein in his brain that's how stubborn he
is
they can fix this it's a it's a blockage
he's not getting enough oxygen to his
brain that's what it's going on it's we
passed out and like we could fix this
nope and he left
so now he's like struggling
struggling and my grandma's in the hole
in the steering wheel now
and i can see my grandma's like happier
it's awesome my grandma's not a young
lady she's not [ __ ] 40 and doing this
she's like still acting like that around
my grandpa at like 60 70. uh-huh it's
[ __ ] up crazy
but this past couple months
when she said they're going on a trip i
go
that's because grandpa can't say [ __ ]
whoa
they never been on vacation you're
leaving where yeah right and my grandma
goes no we're going italia and all this
i go
are you really [ __ ] going to another
country grandma he's letting you that's
how i thought like he's letting you
uh-huh that's how my whole family is all
my uncles and should still like hide
their drinks if my grandpa comes to a
party
they're grown men my god mommy hides his
beer when he had it and put it behind
his arm oh [ __ ] grab a don't drink or
smoke means you're a loser if you're not
working 24 7. yeah and uh that's why you
all have a good work ethic though all of
us always work our ass off
anyway
i pick up my grandpa guys i'm sorry it's
a long story but i feel like
i pick up my grandpa put the car he's
like
it's your car
my grandpa's all like
wow i'm like yeah
yeah you're always telling me i need to
work hard my firework and [ __ ] you but
he like you never seen my car he's like
this is your car i'm like yeah grandpa
wow
like yeah get in the car [ __ ]
grandpa
i was like yeah it's a win for me [ __ ]
you i like my grandpa he's just
growing up
monster yeah now very cool chill very
cool guy he's
chill now we get in the car remember my
grandma's all upbeat 25 years younger
than this [ __ ] and [ __ ] my
grandma's like we're going to [ __ ]
germany she's all hyped up my grandma's
german and portuguese raisin in makapuko
she's not mexican that's why i'm very
white and german
my grandpa's from the jungle yeah that's
where i get this part
it offset it's very odd
but my grandma's from wakapu we should
go in the gym like wow all my grandma's
brothers are like six five six six
that's why all my uncle i'm the shortest
person my family by the way guys only
one not over six foot some [ __ ]
some [ __ ] i'll [ __ ] beat
everybody up though so i would say yeah
you guys follow me
tolerance i do more drugs and i'll fight
all of you
but not for real i'm not being a dick in
my head like yeah you taller i'll fight
you though i'll win [ __ ] um
anyway my grandma grandpa get in the car
i put the car in a nice car yeah put it
in before i leave
the train station to take him to their
hotel right
my grandpa my grandpa
in english he speaks english but doesn't
do it all the time you don't give a [ __ ]
my grandma's behind me rosie's in the
front my grandpa's behind rosie and i
can see my rear view my grandpa and he
goes
you know
he just starts off like that i'm like
what are you gonna say grandpa you don't
ever talk about like oh yeah you make
conversation what the [ __ ] you got to
say goes
you know
grandma thinks she's going to leave me
on the other side of the world that's
why we're going on this trip
a little chino
i'll be back before she's back
in perfect english and my grandma
[Laughter]
just starts laughing i'm like
grandma that was a fast laugh
are you really gonna leave him on the uh
did you tell him this in his dementia
state i'm leaving you in italy i hate i
don't know what she did i'm like
thinking like
house burned down almost
did you start that fire grandma the day
you're leaving to go look [ __ ]
it could have all been gone we're going
on the trip like i i hope i hope in my
head my grandma's getting a couple
points back redemption a little bit but
when my grandpa said that my grandpa my
grandma laughed and i was like i did
this to rosie
and i can see her
i'm trying to stay forward cause i don't
want my grandma to see my side face all
right
so we try then we go pass a billboard i
get into their [ __ ] hotel i get them
a baller ass hotel they were like what
the [ __ ] i was just trying to make him
like yeah grandma i got you
grandpa gets out of the car i get the
luggage and as he's getting luggage he
goes
you know
your grandma's taking me on this trip
she thinks she's gonna leave me on the
he repeats the same [ __ ] he's really
thinking about it yeah did he forget
that he said it
did he just want to really reiterate to
us that that's what he thinks
because i was thinking
i told my sister go before him my
grandmother said this ago do you think
grandma's gonna leave grandpa to like
just die in like the streets of italy or
something take his passport
and just leave him i'll dementia i'll
dimension it out like i would go like
this
i wouldn't say a word
i wouldn't say a word
she deserves every piece of life that
she gets to have now damn i wouldn't say
a word
it's like uh
when you find one of the
auschwitz doctors and you see him you're
like oh they're beating his ass
i don't see [ __ ] that old man
that's how i feel like oh [ __ ]
but that's the feeling i got like
i hope so grandma i hope you believe his
nest for your not really but like if you
did i'm going to say that he said that
to me i'm going to take that one to the
grave
and i'm going to like grandma
i ain't going to say [ __ ]
so i get into their room there's a robot
at the front and you order food get on
the robot take it to your door and my
grandpa's like what the [ __ ] i'm like
damn rosie you score yeah you're making
my grandpa impressive [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ]
him not for real but i'm like yeah [ __ ]
yeah
and uh i get up to the room and i'm like
this is a small room and open the door
is a [ __ ] apartment it was just a
little living room like
[ __ ]
and i'm sitting there
looking downstairs i get up all this
snack [ __ ] i come up like all right
grandma bye and i'm like all right
grandpa i go to shake his hand he goes
he gives me a hug i'm like what the [ __ ]
and he sits down i just sitting down and
goes to us
you know your grandma thinks she's going
to leave
she thinks i'm not oh i'm too weak right
now but little does she know i'll be
back before she's back
he says it again to me and my grandma
goes
and like the look on her face made me go
grandma
yeah that laugh was uh
that's the last she gave when
i don't know what to believe and i went
have a great trip and i closed the door
and left and told rosie cause i'm like
if it happens it [ __ ] happens i ain't
gonna say [ __ ] but let you guys know out
there yes i would i would let my
grandpa's demise happen for my grandma
for sure
just for some color purple payback
but
that's what happened
guys i picked them up and that's what my
grandpa said three [ __ ] times it
doesn't sound like he was like not he
was just really thinking about it it
wasn't like i think he was responsible
i think so
she probably was shouting that [ __ ] at
him
my grandma know i
it's like walking on eggshells around my
grandpa uh-huh for the past 75 years so
i don't know i get it
made me so happy inside to think like
i just i would like was i like to
imagine my baby jesus was playing league
guitar for the leonard skinner band like
some talladega knights back i like to
imagine my grandma's trip just pushing
my grandpa off into the streets
she put him on a little boat and just
no lie
dude every day she was texting me i was
wondering like she can send me a picture
of both of them i didn't see a picture
of both of them her with a different
dude
obviously dude for the past couple weeks
i've been like
on a little bit thinking like dude i
really hope my if this happens my
grandma doesn't smart that's all i keep
thinking like i hope she doesn't get
arrested over some weird [ __ ] my
grandma's great um i don't think she
would do that but if she did i'd be
right beside her well could you imagine
harboring resentment for [ __ ] 55
years on that level
i mean
my grandma grabbed a wedding picture in
the living room since i was a kid my
grandma looks like she has a gun to her
back
she's like this
in her wedding patient that's [ __ ]
horrible it's the picture that's been
there since i was born and it's just a
constant reminder her
my grandpa's as old as me looking and
she well no don't take that back i look
young my grandpa looks like a 30
something year old man brown suit
my grandpa had like six other kids left
his whole family stole my grandma it's a
long story bro i have a whole weird
story but my grandpa is one of the
hardest working people on the planet
though i will say that
but other than that i don't know what
else to say about that man
a little little mexican history lesson
my grandpa was the lead
foreman for all the mexican laborers
when they america gave him a grant to
let mexicans come and work in the fields
my grandpa's the guy in the pictures
with the hat
i didn't know that until i was in
college studying it
and i saw a picture then my grandma my
grandfather used to work oh shut the
[ __ ] up and my grandpa is in the [ __ ]
history books my grandpa greg rajo
gregorio that's his name he's in the
front like this with the big hat the
former because he spoke english and
spanish and he ran all the tomato fields
he's in the he was the guy on the on the
paper
like you are the foreman like he's he's
the guy that runs the fields and then
when they go back to mexico he stays
here gets the new guys comes back works
back and forth
the first
mexican uh sanctioned workers from
mexico my grandpa ran him
that's that's how old he is god damn
that's the old my grandpa is
monster
but i remember i saw that go
hmm
sick all right that's my grandpa that's
pretty [ __ ] tight just thinking like
yeah that's why i work so hard cuz look
look at this guy
um but yeah that's what happened
so learned about in college and going
shut the [ __ ] up
i'm interested to see how this turns out
we're back okay
i don't know if we knew the conclusion
yesterday okay
she said
water is better than america and no
one's fat in europe that's what she took
from that water's way better here
water's too expensive there and no one's
fat that's all she said that's what she
took over waiting your whole life to
travel
no she has pictures she loved it she
talked about that's what i took from her
conversation like if i could take some
[ __ ] youtube keyword line grandma
the water sucks and everyone's fat all
right
um but yeah so that's what happened uh
when he made it back yeah he's fine i
mean you know i didn't i didn't talk to
him but i'm assuming
i'm assuming yeah don't ya don't believe
her
no my uncle picked him up i'm sure he
would be like yo where's my dad
he caught a different flight oh [ __ ] he
decided to stay a little longer and
sightsee
from the alleys of italy
[ __ ] street rat
anyway that's what happened this weekend
guys all right this past two weeks uh
what are we at like 1 30
yeah
136. nice nice all right all right um i
have one more
point
all right
this is the first time we're actually
keeping this episode tight yeah
doing quite the job yeah yeah yeah it's
a crazy [ __ ] week guys we got to get
this thing ready
there's a lot of [ __ ] going on this week
a lot but we are making power moves
towards
us not having to handle so much and be
able to
just focus on the show as we always say
but that is that is our lives that is
the goal it's the mission so that is
what we do when we're not doing this
well and i know people are gonna ask in
the comments
dopey shop this is the tropical sword
rise these are all my friend hash house
and no you cannot buy these
they're not in stores but these are
dopeyshop.com
i have another baby joint i should light
um
sorry for everyone in the car i pulled
out a giant joint when i said baby joy
that was why i laughed like
ah
aha that's how hook lasts when he starts
going to the jungle bee
that's a good movie man
damn looks a good movie dude i just
watched it again the other day uh-huh up
there i went and bought some ray-bans
the glasses i was wearing
and i want these are very
robin williams
hook
pre-neverland and the guy was like they
are i'm buying them from this
[ __ ] he knew what i was talking
about uh-huh by the way yes i do this in
public guys like uh very uh i just
compare it because the person gets i go
so you know what i'm talking about did
you go into peter pan being a creep with
him
no no i didn't he talked about coffee
for too long when i went i don't know
about coffee
i told him like 22 times i don't drink
coffee because rosie bought this bag
big-ass the coffee machine but she
bought one for that so amazing
he was explaining to me about the mixes
and like bro i don't drink toffee
and he heard me the twelve time
nice dude though nice dude
um
so i'm gonna light this joint up and i
wanna let you guys in on a little bts
if you did not know all right if you did
not know
season four story time is on all right
is on has started
one a month i've still got to catch up
on three episodes
because i started in march or yeah march
so this last episode you may have heard
this story
it's actually from the season one of
story time on the dopagiol channel
called hard drug confessions it's about
the night i accidentally smoked
methamphetamines on top of this wee bowl
by this girl named jennifer and it
pissed me off got all twacked out threw
up it was disgusting first night i drank
gin
first night in the cab
all bad
cab and cabbie i was confused there
first night i took a cab anywhere i've
never been to cab before taxi gotcha and
uh
i took a cab to smoke a cabbie
and then uh
anyway season four if you don't know if
you like story time i now do
reenactments
so say it's a story about meth i reenact
everything so if you want to see what i
look like at 14 years old
i went and got a wig
i went and got the same kind of shirt
that i would always i always wore a
shirt like that but it was more green i
couldn't find one
and i reenacted this scene but the
reason i'm bringing this up is
there's a throw up scene in this episode
right you should go watch it it's called
worst night ever
season four episode 2 of story time
just on the dopagiola channel it's
called worst night ever i don't want to
call it hard drug confessions i don't
want to mix it up because the first hard
drug confession there's three stories i
only did one in this reenactment so the
reenactment is when i was 14 years old
actually smoked meth right
so there's a throw up scene and i had to
make fake throw up
i am on the i mean we're filming i got
like five people with me
i don't like
hiccups i don't like having to go to the
store and get [ __ ] i don't want to have
to [ __ ] wait in line for 20 minutes
because that 20 minutes turns into 40
minutes and then the drive back and then
we're an hour and a half past filming
then it's late then it's one in the
morning and i'm tired trying to film
it's not the same energy so i like to
try to keep things tight
so i went to the store down the street
and the only soup i wanted to get
campbell's chunky soup
or some kind of soup to mix with some
juice put in my mouth and make fake
throw up
that's what i was gonna do
all they had was ramen they only had
shrimp or chicken and i'm not doing
shrimp
so i had rosie take all the ramen
packets out take the chicken pieces out
and rinse the ramen just rinse it rinse
it rinse it under water underwater to
get that chicken flavor taste out of
there so i didn't taste it while i
chopped it up so i had to cook a bunch
of ramen chop it up hello small with the
vegetables in it still no chicken taste
no nothing right i was like what i
thought
and i got some kerns you guys know
kearns juice that liquidy
thick juice you probably shouldn't drink
it
kern so i got the strawberry banana i
had rosie mix it
and the chop of the
ramen put into a cup it looked
disgusting
right
i do not eat meat at all
i smell meat cooking makes me feel
nauseous i it's
dumbest [ __ ] i ever said in my life i
never thought i would not eat meat let
alone
that's for real i feel sick
so when i go to like barbecue spots i
just can't even go no more i used to go
to my korean barbecue and just get rice
and noodles and they would cook their
[ __ ] but that it was overwhelming dude i
felt like i could taste it
it's just it's not for me all right do
your thing i don't give a [ __ ] you eat
meat just not for me
so i do this throw up scene i my trench
shout out to trent
he puts an apple box which is a big
piece of wood that people stand on in
movies put an apple box on my chest he
ratchet strapped it like a truck for
trucks the straps for ratchets
he ratchet straps into my body uh drills
a [ __ ] camera mount into the chest of
it now there's a camera pointed at me
like remember in the hangover and they
wake up
and he's all [ __ ] up that scene like
so it's moving so the camera moves with
me and the background looks all crazy
look all disoriented
we did that but i had him ratchet strap
it so tight i could barely breathe like
because remember the woods against my
ribs like on the front of my ribs and
the ratchet straps against the back of
my ribs tight super tight so i wanted
the shot to be good so i was like
tighten it to i could almost not breathe
because all i need to do is fake throw
up it's not like i got a [ __ ]
i'm not smoking i'm fine
i press play
i scoop the chicken soup
ramen into my mouth
right with the kerns mouthful
right and i breathe out
and once i breathe in
and once i breathe in my nose all i see
you know smell and taste go together all
i can taste
and imagine is chicken
and chicken bones
like the meat that's closest to the bone
that has the red on it that's what i'm
imagining in my mouth there's no chicken
in it it's the flavoring it's still
there all i taste is chicken
oh sorry in the scene in real life i
smoked like five cigarettes when i was
all messed up so in the scene in the
reenactment i went and bought cigarettes
i cut them down when i got to the edge
so it looked like i smoked them but all
the scenes of me smoking i really had to
smoke it i couldn't go
you wouldn't know like we'll hit the sig
so i'm like
and every time i see the scene cuts i'm
like
so i'm really smoking cigs so i smoke
the cigs i'm like
oh i don't like to eat that much before
i film because i feel bloated and then i
want to feel bloated and tired i want to
be alert
so
i didn't eat that day
so hey i'm smoking six
two cigarettes i'm like
two cigarettes but fully probably like
almost one sig i had to like puff
so i taste six then i put this [ __ ]
camera strap last shot of the night
i put this camera strapped to me so
tight i put the chicken soup the current
mix in my mouth i breathe in
i breathe out and i just taste the
chicken
so violent and in my mouth it's dry in
my throat from cigarettes
but in here i'm like that i'm about to
[ __ ] yeah with the with the with the
chopped up noodles and curtains
so if you watch the story time that
throw up looked so [ __ ] real
it looked
better than i ever could imagine
we built a [ __ ] plexiglas box over
the camera so i could throw up right on
the lens all trent really went out
he's the man dude he [ __ ] built this
box over so i can throw up straight on
it
that's why that scene looks so real all
right
so
i taste the chicken at automatic go no
no no no no open the door i'm doing the
scene right now and i go
so if you watch the episode that's real
panic on my face i was tasting chicken
and cigs for the cigs i haven't smoked
[ __ ] 12 years
10 years chicken i haven't i haven't
eaten meat since 2016.
i don't want that
i don't want the smell makes me feel
sick i tasted it and automatically get
out of my way
so if you watch the video
i throw up that scene right all the food
and then you see me go
and throw up more that was a real throw
up
but you guys know that second heave was
all real deal throw up maybe i'll get
the whole clip and post it somewhere
because i start [ __ ] freaking out and
panicking right after because i start
throwing up and dry heaving but what
happens when you throw up in dry eve you
need room to expand
the ratchet strap is so tight on my ribs
and the board when i go
oh it hurts so bad i just go
and i try to gag like only the first
part not the whole
because i can't expand but trent was
laughing so hard
he didn't hear me go tread dread trent i
need like you can see in the clip like
trying to help me out mail me and you
can't hear me because he's laughing i
get like
[ __ ] i was like i got upset like i
thought he just was [ __ ] around yeah
but he couldn't hear me i'm like trent
[ __ ] help me i couldn't keep like
yeah
because it was so tight on my ribs so i
had like like the feeling of throw up my
throat but i couldn't let it out because
i was like i'm gonna suffocate dre i
can't i'm like so in the video i'm like
hurry up hurry up [ __ ] it please and
then he just starts
he starts gagging so it takes like 15
seconds to bam and as soon as he pops it
i can start like dry heaving and [ __ ]
because it felt like my rib wasn't
crushed
it felt like
like it was going to come in like it was
so tight so this [ __ ] wouldn't move yeah
and i didn't think about what if you
actually throw up and you start driving
and i couldn't reach a strap in the back
and no one could help me because they're
all [ __ ] dying laughing and don't
know
that um i can't breathe
so
the second is real puke
and i'll post the other clip but you can
see me like
i can i can start like not breathing and
right after i'm just
dude i was out there for like 15 minutes
just throwing up like spit bile not food
anymore cause i need yeah but i was
throwing a spit ball i could only taste
the chicken i don't drink soda anymore
and i drink a dr pepper and it made me
feel even worse
so if you ever [ __ ] go you're late oh
this fool's not gonna give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you and your whole families
i smoked a cig almost brought my [ __ ]
rib yeah and put chicken in my mouth you
got some cloud points off there all
right for the [ __ ] video but the
video came out so
good i have almost broken my wrist and
my hip for
youtube videos before uh i forgot about
the hip one until rosie said it and then
i almost broke my knee on that pov video
i [ __ ] jumped off this big ass
concrete thing and straightened my knee
out where i when i hit and it like the
the the
straighten made me pop up yeah i thought
i broke my leg i looked at [ __ ] beer
like
i looked down like okay [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's not but it was black it was like
bruising
i thought i broke my [ __ ] leg i was
so pissed this was two years ago
but um
yes the new story time came out bomb the
next one i don't know what to do
i don't know which one because some of
my stories i was at the courthouse i got
to get a courthouse and actors i can get
the courthouse it's the actors for me
mm-hmm that's the hard part yeah
we can't just have og be the prosecutors
you can't i can't
you could it probably should
you'd probably be amazing at that hey
fools so like so like what's up fool you
like you're in trouble
you son of a [ __ ] sort of a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
oh yeah you son of a [ __ ] you do it
[ __ ]
did you do it tell me the truth
with the gavel
and lopes
no i can't og be the actor so that's why
some of the story times are hard to do
but
sum it up that's the bts information if
you watch a lot of story time that
second heave was real throw up and that
panic in my face was a real panic
because that's when i realized i cannot
breathe and there's throw up in my
throat and i can't
fully expand
i can't expand it was enough to even
puke nope
nope
i'll find the whole clip i have the
whole clip saying hopefully that'll be
the only time in life that ever happens
dude i didn't think about it that was
dangerous
i could have [ __ ] choked or broke my
rib
worth it
super i would have wrote it off by part
of the video hospital uh-huh
hospital vlog
cts what do you mean like i broke my rib
and vlogged it
could you imagine breaking my rib as a
smoker i won't be able to smoke for
months
one cough go back to the hospital oh
hell no i knew a girl like 2013 that
collapsed her whole one of her lungs
the whole thing collapsed
i thought i collapsed my lungs once
based on what she told me
she was dabbing some unclean ass [ __ ]
she was she takes i mean this [ __ ]
girl marty when i say she take grams ram
dabs grams multiple grams
and really chunking she's really
chugging she's really going she's
[ __ ] she's really really dabbing this
[ __ ] i was so [ __ ] shocked
um
like two months later i saw her and she
wasn't smoking we asked her like what
the [ __ ] i smell she's like dude she
told the story she was taking this huge
ass dab
and then she said she just started
feeling like she couldn't breathe in
and then she passed out
and then she woke up on the way to the
hospital like
she couldn't breathe they got there and
they had like and i guess they inflate
it back up
to a surgery where they can put a hole
and her [ __ ] lung collapsed and it's
bad it's better
but what
and then one time i thought i did i was
taking this
ridiculous ass dab it was about like
three not really three grams but i mean
it was slaps
and i took it i remember i breathed out
i went
and i couldn't breathe back in and i
went did i collapse both am i dead and
something am i gonna be the first
[ __ ] to die off with smoking
and then it turned back on
i was so scared i was with a room full
of people like [ __ ]
should i when should i panic uh-huh when
should i let these guys count down to
panic in five yep and then turn back
yeah
yeah so don't take slabs unless you're
ready for that um
what do we have marty
i say like 149.
151 you are highly on point sir
pretty close
all right all right
already got anything else you want to
talk about man
i'm uh
it's a busy week it's a weird week yeah
so this was a really weird weird week
with the filming last week we filmed
late with tony hawk and then we had the
surgery and everything this week i was
in merced for three days too that's why
for the past two weeks in a row yeah
but big shout out to buffalo man big
shout out to everybody going through
horrible [ __ ] we just want to come
through and make everybody forget about
that [ __ ] on mondays
yeah dude a lot of people can ask this
to like go over everything go do talk
about like what bro me and marty have
for like it's only beating it into the
ground
and yeah i got so many dms about the
situation at buffalo and i didn't
respond to anybody just
because i don't know what the [ __ ] to
say yeah it's like what do you want me
to say
i can't change [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] up
i i didn't know what happened to you
posted like
the buffalo thing what are you just
still talking about yeah i looked like
what the [ __ ]
people are weird people are creeps
yeah just
kept unraveling as even more and more
and more more horrible
you know that's i grew up a lot of my
childhood less than a mile from there
you
know
you were telling me like i'm trying to
check on my homies
yeah i mean i'm trying to check out my
friends see if they're [ __ ] good
uh my first thought was i mean that was
my first thought like who was in that
store
well before i even knew it was a match
like what the deal was like a million
thoughts went through my [ __ ] head
but
you know it's it's it's horrible and it
did shine you know it is it is weird
because it's like
in a this is the second biggest city in
new york state buffalo is
and it's like there's really is only
like two or three grocery stores like on
the whole half of that city on the whole
east side and i was thinking i was
considering that like that is weird
you know because i was just
considering all my childhood riding
around jamal playing basketball over
there and [ __ ] just like that's that
little top's over there like yeah that's
it it's just
i don't know man it's [ __ ] it's it's
chilling i had
they didn't really bill it as a mass
shooting but there was a mass shooting
in the building i used to work in
actually too
about two years after um i stopped
working there i was telling you i got my
first job my first real job when i was
16 at this building downtown right next
to where like if you look at the buffalo
skyline there's one tall tower right
beneath it right where our baseball team
plays directly across the street
and
there was a restaurant on the first
floor called the city grill
and we were on the third floor
and yeah it was like because it was like
gang related or some [ __ ] they didn't
call it label it like a mass shooting
but it was a dude just standing across
the street just unloading on the whole
restaurant
and a bunch of people died that's
horrible yeah
so
i don't know man there's been
i just
it's just sad when
any any under any circumstance i don't
know what to say there's nothing to say
it's too horrible i just basically
don't want to [ __ ] go anywhere do
anything for the rest of my life on some
level
i've already been like that yeah
no i get it
but and it's like it makes you feel like
an irresponsible parent to send your kid
to school
but it's been like that
so i don't know
weird
but
yeah i don't know people been asking
this you guys better talk about it like
all right but i don't really want to
beat it into your [ __ ] heads more
than the news is like it's sad it's a
horrible [ __ ] let's
we can acknowledge the [ __ ] and how sad
it is and move on
we have to sit here and go into the
psychology of why somebody does stupid
[ __ ]
yeah that's not our business but it is
we sit here and big buffalo up all the
time and talk about it and [ __ ] we gotta
acknowledge the [ __ ] yeah
100
like i said i didn't know anything i
don't watch the news you told me yeah it
was horrible i recommend when [ __ ] like
that happens don't watch these [ __ ]
videos don't watch any of that [ __ ] it's
super don't put the energy around you
can't unwatch these videos horrible [ __ ]
horrible
disgusting
but maybe we should ask that earlier
we're all [ __ ]
i don't know man yeah yeah we just
wanted to officially just kind of touch
on that [ __ ] our love out and just
everybody we're not forgetting about it
and
still still on my mind you know
i don't know it just
has kind of gone into the batch of
things that way in my mind i don't know
but
yeah man shout out to buffalo shout out
to everybody going through something but
it's mondays we're [ __ ] hanging out
exactly also stop beating up freddie
gibbs i like freddie gibbs
all right buffalo freddie gibbs come on
the podcast don't beat up freddie gibbs
man you ever hear alfredo
all right he made thriller
thriller
that's why i feel like don't do nothing
bad
that video didn't really get out there
all like that it seemed kind of like i'm
just more like yeah
you guys are too good of [ __ ] artists
you're too good at putting music
together to be [ __ ] shout out to
freddie gibbs for still going on stage
that night though he got his ass beat by
his what baby the butcher's dudes i
don't know who it was it was like a long
distance shot at him at a restaurant and
the whole restaurant was full of dudes
just stomping them out but then that
night he went on stage at the uh town
ballroom and performed
swollen up and [ __ ] dude freddie gibbs i
[ __ ] love that fool
too hard but also leave freddy gems
alone
all right let him just wrap his ass off
talks a lot of [ __ ] dogs a lot of [ __ ]
let him talk his [ __ ] man leave him
alone man uh he's chilling i think he's
hardest but it's [ __ ] up because him
and benny made a lot of music together
like some of the benny's top songs with
him
i don't like it
i don't like that at all because yeah
that's i don't know i'm not saying
anyone's right or wrong either way i'm
just saying
come on man you guys make too much money
don't do that to have some petty [ __ ] i
don't know don't fight it's too much
money to be fighting just let it go
for for hip-hop please
for the sake of people that want more
albums
don't do this that's how i feel you know
how many artists out there i wish i
could have more albums of yeah
for real come on
that's sad to think about
i know
[ __ ]
um
all right
let's try to be like well i'm beating i
don't know i don't know what else to say
like
it's so sad yeah but we got a bunch of
exciting guests on the way guys we're we
just
made a big push for a bunch of new
guests we got a bunch of exciting moves
going on behind the scenes we got the
spotify [ __ ] going on we got the [ __ ]
all kinds of stuff going on to level
this [ __ ] up so yeah if you're on
spotify you can leave reviews please
leave us a [ __ ] review
there's five there's like thousands of
five star reviews it is [ __ ] cool to
see it on spotify yeah oh that was apple
apple i know apple for sure spotify
doesn't have reviews it should oh it's
apple then thank you guys wherever
you're at just appreciate it thank you
so much
um
yes we have that and possibly a new well
no not possibly got a new setup coming
all right we're going to be very
this
and marty's going to no longer be in the
distance
we're trying to bring this together
and make a table where marty and i could
be right here but we're more cohesive
yes so guess not doing this
huh
gotcha
and looking back this way all right we
want it to all be together we're trying
to figure it out but we figured it out
and it's gonna be [ __ ] cool so thank
you guys so much for being here also you
know what tripped me out
huh
last week's episode all right sorry i'm
still thinking about it
what the [ __ ] we finally had him on all
right
[ __ ] tony hawkins watch that [ __ ]
tony hawk episode three come on man get
the [ __ ] out of here dude
coney hot contact high pitchers are so
you to him smiling him having a good
time smiling
smoke all in the air i was talking about
ridiculous [ __ ] crazy to me it's just
we had 20 minutes before the episode
started i wish we would have recorded
uh-huh because jason ellis was uh tony
hawk got here early he got here on time
yeah so me and tony hawk talked for like
20 minutes tony hawk drove off from san
diego for the show yeah he was [ __ ]
awesome and
i wish we had most of that on camera we
talked about some good [ __ ] a lot about
jackass actually yeah yeah yeah a lot of
good behind the scenes [ __ ] i wish we
would have recorded what a g though
shows up just by himself comes in
with us [ __ ] chilling yeah he was
cool as hell man look like wayne gretzky
they're pretty pretty resemble each
other pretty well
well no legends
or chris collinsworth i gotta look him
up chris collinsworth the announcer
without michaels in the nfl hi chris all
right all michael's the he's playing
football he used to be on the guinness
book of world records announcer host
okay
kind of looks like chris collinsworth
uh-huh everybody out there in the
comments yeah no huh it's pretty pretty
spot on description
um
okay
yeah [ __ ] insane
sorry i still can't believe that [ __ ] um
also shout out to thedobeshop.com you
can see next to marty's head you can see
that the [ __ ] uh nice little neon we
got going
uh yeah there's just there's a lot
happening guys pushtrees.com we're doing
so much we're doing stuff every day
we're doing more
and more [ __ ] every day so thank you
guys for supporting it thank you for
being here
um anything else you want to say marty
that's it thank you guys we appreciate
you we got
a bunch of cool exciting new [ __ ] coming
on these next couple weeks let's keep
locked in tell a friend
let's keep this [ __ ] going tell
homie we're about we just hit 180 000
subscribers guys thank you so [ __ ]
much
thank you guys thank you so [ __ ] much
uh
we just marty did this thing today where
we added up
a couple episodes for a certain brand
and
there's 24 million impressions on like
four episodes it's a lot that's [ __ ]
crazy
knowing that like
dude some of these impressions are out
doing the dope as yolo channel
that watch time is out doing the
dopestyle channel that's [ __ ] unreal
so thanks guys thanks for hanging out
with us and thanks for being here and
shout out to everybody that meets me in
public and the first thing they say is
the podcast
that's
insane to me i told you a [ __ ] kid
this is this he must be like 20 but he
drove by in a work truck he stopped and
he goes
hey
i watch you and marty all the time
shit's [ __ ] awesome and then he drove
off let's go yeah
[ __ ] yeah
that was sick that's the best [ __ ] ever
that's [ __ ] i will think about yeah i
was on a [ __ ] face time i felt so bad
too i was like
oh well i was in the middle of a meeting
and i just put it down like oh sorry
guys oh yeah i just had to like
pretend like a glitch or something yeah
i didn't want to like i'm gonna call man
i just had to like no i'll put in my
pocket make it look like it glitched
that's what i did
but yeah shout out to everybody out
there thank you thank you so much shout
out to everybody i [ __ ] saw randomly
and merced uh wouldn't watch the movie
my dad had been that theater since i was
a kid
and yeah that's pretty much it man i
want to buy some property or merced
i i talked about the certain company and
a certain business in a certain spot now
there's that business there and they're
killing it i'm so upset i should have
did it when i was a kid i mean i was
younger i should have started trying to
invest in it who gives a [ __ ] uh yeah
anyway vindemer said six days in the
past two weeks which is so odd to me i
haven't been there in that so long to be
there that long is so odd
days go by so slow
there's so there's nothing to do
i might just start a business or
something because other than that you're
just sitting
and i remember all the times just
sitting
i don't like it
i don't like it i'd rather be tired all
the time yes from working
also shout out to everybody out there
working their [ __ ] ass off if you're
in the bathroom hiding right now and
you're smoking weed by the dumpsters
pretending to take the trash out and
[ __ ]
i feel you i understand we're all there
we're all once there if you want to stay
there it's [ __ ] cool but if you don't
make it a point to get the [ __ ] out of
there and you will all right think
positive stay positive thinking about
negative [ __ ] doesn't do anything but
draw more negative energy towards you
that dark cloud all that [ __ ] so if
that's what you're going through right
now i see you guys comments remember
we've all done it we've all been there
maybe currently maybe not but we've all
[ __ ] been there
and it'll pass right that's pretty much
what every episode's about okay i'm just
[ __ ] high now but uh
yeah it's the first time i'm smoking
weed
this and tony hawk this is purple weed
i haven't gotten any og this week so i
smoked purple we would tony at the end
of it go whoa i gotta switch up my week
oh yeah cause it was probably though
it's like some runs or some shambling
that's a different high not
uh
so yeah i feel different right now i
like it um
thanks guys thank you so much before you
get out of here i know i know we're
dragging it out twitter go follow us on
twitter dope as usual podcast boom bring
it up right about here
and then
instagram we just hit like 70 something
thousand [ __ ] thank you guys super
[ __ ] cool boom here's our instagram
dope's usual podcast
sorry
all right thank you so much for being
here oh we have tick-tock too don't we
yeah we have tick-tock too many to get
that thing going to start doing more we
might need a social media person at this
point
it's coming it's coming we
we need some help
um but guys thank you so much for being
here thank you for hanging out with us
thank you for everything
uh i went through a couple episodes the
other day and just seeing the change
from season one to now is [ __ ]
awesome yes wow our lights are in the
wall this is awesome
um yeah thank you guys so much for being
here thank you for everything for
supporting for marty and i uh marty you
were in a lot of blue
i just noticed that right yes oh yeah
yes i am i had to have to show the
[ __ ] support today um
i think that's it man i'm just [ __ ]
high and stoked
i don't film till tomorrow after this
i'm gonna go like actually just sit i
played def jam fight for new york for
five hours with my mom's boyfriend the
other day
uh-huh
didn't answer my phone didn't do work
smoked joints or smoked pens got high as
[ __ ] off vape pens
and played games
first time since i was probably 18 or 19
years old that i sat and did not do
anything else but get high and play
games what passed with methamphetamine
oh i wasn't met the man i was a noriega
and then dude david banner
yeah that [ __ ] in that game try
try to fight me with david man i will
[ __ ] your [ __ ] up david banner is
the hulk
in that game anyway where's the petition
that jam bring it back
bring it back
def jam fight for the west coast or def
jam fight for something bring it back
throw sound cloud rappers in there make
it happen all right put some
[ __ ] in there you wouldn't
expect just [ __ ] bring it back please
do some more [ __ ] could you imagine
a [ __ ] game where you're like i'm
gonna be kendrick lamar i'm gonna fight
you all right who are you ah they put
takashi 6'9 in here
everyone's gonna fight everybody
i mean could you imagine that yeah that
would be the biggest [ __ ] game in the
world for a minute
dev jam is such a good game already the
fighting [ __ ] we're trying to get
started
sorry i got lost damn what a good game
fire from new york [ __ ] out of here
throw a [ __ ] i threw danny trail
in front of a [ __ ] subway and one
all right
that joe is joey crack uh-huh let's go
i beat him in one [ __ ] try the
[ __ ] [ __ ] you thought he was [ __ ]
with i did put it on the easy though
i was trying to beat the game real quick
so it was uneasy um snoop dogg
unstoppable
doing kung fu
um sorry for everyone out there that's
like yo you said you were wrapping it up
also you could have changed it too so
[ __ ] you also always i see your comments
you could you're rambling on
[ __ ] change it watch me ramble [ __ ]
you but for everyone else that is here
shout out to you shout out to everybody
with evoking [ __ ] we see who else see
elizabeth in there all the time
dude there's so many names bg gal
b
gal for
i can't remember the letters i see so
many of the names shout out to you guys
for always [ __ ] being here
literally all the time thank you demons
is always in there i could go on and on
there's so many [ __ ] names shout out
terps and caicos for getting his signed
tray in the mail oh yeah that's right
huh yeah sick everywhere marty's been
doing some giveaways man just follow us
on instagram all right my instagram got
to leave
so much so just
find marty's which is drastic graphics
and i'm sure that he had posted me
recently
or follow the podcast there you go
and that's my new newest instagram is
there all right we like to keep it fresh
yeah we like to keep it we like to keep
it going we don't like making accounts
grow we like to just in and out in and
out it's a
it's a turn gate it's a turning point
game what is it called it's the turnover
yeah i like to put about 15 accounts in
a year
high turnover the high turnover rate for
accounts over here i i don't i like
underscores they're trap accounts we're
just kind of yep yeah i make them just
to get them deleted
so no one else can make those accounts
that's the whole point mainly just to
waste our time
i like making new emails and ips i love
getting new phones
i like having to download and back up my
phone to my computer
i love it i just freed up six terabytes
if you know what we can have lots of new
accounts all right so yes gotcha guys
thanks
um also [ __ ] you instagram
really playing me over here
now i got a mushroom ad on my instagram
page today
first legal shrooms to your door but i
can't [ __ ] post thedopashop.com
[ __ ] instagram it's okay who gives a
[ __ ] uh guys thank you so much for being
here uh i know i said that about 20
maybe 21 minutes ago thank you so much
for being here thank you for everyone in
the [ __ ] chat thank you for being
here drop a [ __ ] like marty
remember at the beginning of this
episode when we're talking just put boom
drop a like below because i never
remember to say this [ __ ] and when you
like like the [ __ ] the algorithm likes
that and it goes hey i'm gonna suggest
this video to more people
so that's why we always ask for that
thank you so much
so um i think that's it
are you uh changing batteries
okay gotcha so uh from everybody for
everyone out there thank you so much for
watching i know i said it 62 times thank
you for watching thank you for hanging
out with us thank you for being here
so much more [ __ ] on the way like a lot
we have a lot of different guests lined
up there's a lot of [ __ ] coming okay a
lot of guests you wouldn't expect
hold on tony hawk
jason ellis very unexpected
i think the one i'm talking about people
are going to be even more hyped about
and i don't know if that was even
possible
but it could be
we're about to crack the [ __ ] out of
some sports interviews
and it's getting crazy the fact that
these athletes are coming on the show
we're able to do this some intense
[ __ ] athletes
we're locking some [ __ ] in all right
with certain athletes that you're gonna
go get the [ __ ] out of here so thank you
guys so much for supporting the show
enough for us to be able to do this i
mean jason ellis tony hawk were here
last week
a little over a year into the show guys
come on thank you you guys did that [ __ ]
marty [ __ ] help another [ __ ]
to podcast now we have our own
rivaling numbers of the podcast you
worked on
yes not in a bad way like a competition
more more of like amazing
it's like when you're a kid and you make
a three for the first time you're like
uh-huh yeah exactly i've been watching
these fools make threes this whole time
god no not for real but that's how you
feel like i could do it too
well when you have success it makes you
feel like i can do anything like i can i
can do whatever i want i know i can do
it right
at least i try my best yeah i'm not
scared to try yes not scared to try is
the biggest thing
not getting it done oh you failed to
catch
you try your [ __ ] hardest and the
fact that it's like yeah
now where you have you know i was always
doing [ __ ] but you were always behind
the scenes and now that you're not
i'm telling you like you're so far away
you got to be that's where we're
building a new
look so marty can be right [ __ ] here
no more chords everywhere camera's
about to be sick
um
all right i think that's it let's go
that's it
i wish we could talk [ __ ] about people
and they wouldn't get upset cause i
would love to tell the story you told me
about yesterday oh no we could do a
whole episode yeah we can't i wish we
were allowed to air [ __ ] out because you
got to go like shut the [ __ ] up
let's just people let's just leave it as
the time to airship
yeah no we're we're the nicest guys in
this [ __ ] is the thing
no you don't yeah like it's more like yo
do you want to play
i broke my leg earlier man i don't think
i could heal you my legs broke wait
but you're fine
yeah it's broken
that's the equivalent of
what me and marty are talking about i
know we're just gonna leave you guys
hanging sorry got it sorry
it's imagine trying to have to book a
guest every other week guys imagine
just for free
these peop the people you got to deal
with over time you're into it now you
know like it doesn't stop it never stops
never going to that's okay though let's
just
yeah let's just say
what'd you say just check it off that's
okay yeah keep moving uh-huh like i
tried yeah exactly because you know you
know what's really funny about how i
worded this particular pitch that we're
rent we're dancing around that i'm
talking about
i opened it up by hey out of due
diligence to the fans i just want to
follow up and see
see what's up
because they want you you know like
i know if i know the fans want somebody
even if in my life i'm looking at them a
little bit like i don't know if i would
if i know the fans really want it i'll
swallow what i even my own pride and try
to make it happen in instances
yeah we'll won't go too much we'll leave
it at that but
pretty much this
me and marty are the guys that like yo
you can't come in
like all right i'll see you in a couple
months [ __ ] and you're going to
be letting me come in and you're going
to give me a table
just [ __ ] yeah yeah no we're just uh
it's the best thing you can do the best
thing you could have did to me was like
go
nah i'm good yeah because it's like
a we're never scared to put ourselves
out there but it's like you know nothing
yeah
yeah
[ __ ] are funny though you gotta
do a bunch of extra funny ass [ __ ] yeah
yeah i sold drugs [ __ ] i know
what motherfucker's beating around the
bush yeah like i'm yeah especially like
bro i'm crazy
currently going through real [ __ ] like i
know what you're dancing the day you ask
[ __ ] like my son has his
shoulders split open literally i'm doing
things and i'm still asking literally
yeah
quite [ __ ] literally yeah dude
so
yeah we'll just leave it at that we just
like
like ryan from the office
yeah yeah of course
no just wanted to ask
no worries whatsoever you you do your
thing
exactly go back to work and i'm like
i don't care anymore i tried i tried my
best if the fans asked i've been trying
i'll follow up with you again too [ __ ]
and i'll be i'll have a big smile when i
do it because one day don't ever get
upset yeah if people don't want to it's
not it's like if who cares who gives a
[ __ ]
it's not like we're saying people deny
you and you get so upset you talk about
no no it's not like not what we're
talking about
i'm sorry we can't get too into things
but it
it was more of
my leg just snapped
but no i didn't like wait i can't play
my leg
just say you don't want to play with me
man
don't lie to me
actually you know i'm going to
guadalajara tomorrow i'm actually in the
plane right now i'm actually actually
the skydiving instructor says i need to
put the phone we're facetiming you're at
home yeah you're at home
what was it when daisy pill tries to
hang out with big boy
uh no uh i'm on the move [ __ ]
why is everybody not hanging out with me
that's how i was like
a lot of famous people got their own
[ __ ] going on yeah i get it i get it
we'll just leave it at that one won't
say no more but
the look on marty's face
i'm just happy that's how i feel too
like yeah i'm just happy to do our own
thing yeah where's that [ __ ] tony
hawk on here so give a [ __ ] we're all
hyped we're all stoked uh i would really
like to see action bronze in here i was
thinking that the other day i'd like to
see action bronson here ellen iverson
please god
action bronson allen iverson like people
that i would like to talk to
[Music]
soon those two i would like to have bill
nye on here i think dylan either science
guy would be there somebody in the
comments said judge judy almost shat my
pants in the live chat i don't know if i
want just judy sit away could you
imagine i will go off on judge judy what
if she smokes though
i'm just saying if she tried to pull
some rude [ __ ] to me yeah and it might
be the shortest interview ever yeah it's
true but no in my mind it would just be
riveting we'd be talking about all her
crazy ass oh i would love it if she was
cool but yeah she doesn't seem cool she
might be she might be that it could be a
character never she might be so that's
not [ __ ] she is she's the highest
papers in television yeah did you know
that
you wanna google real quick google judge
judy's net worth and i want to see your
[ __ ] jaw drop
we have a camera on you too so you can
see your jaw drop
judge judy's network i want you to see
what she makes
thank you thank you 500 mil almost yeah
she's the highest paid tv actor
she's the highest paid per year
she's doing the [ __ ] since the [ __ ]
60s
she's worth 440 just right there
that's like without liquidating assets
yeah
she's probably worth a good 600 million
dollars
get this [ __ ] broke down deadbeat dad
out of my courtroom pay her what did you
just say and as season two came she just
started becoming a [ __ ]
but like in a good way like i don't want
to [ __ ] hear it stop talking yeah
when i watch judge judy oh she's scary
that's like joe's mom when i say i used
to be scared of joe's mom that's like
talking to judge judy like you're right
but damn yeah you're crafty yeah you
don't have time for my [ __ ] yeah
exactly oh you see right through me huh
[ __ ] okay but yeah i know judge judy is
all she's nice man i would love to do it
also i think a good one and i think we
might be able to dr phil
oh [ __ ] yeah i think that'd be a good i
think it'd be a good time amazing they'd
be a good talk he used to bug me he
don't bump me no more he's pretty
insightful uh-huh he's talking just
he's speaking from
what's presented and that's logical so i
[ __ ] with that i would love that yeah i
haven't seen everything so don't tell me
that doctor i'm not saying i stand firm
to say what i've seen i've seen two
episodes yeah of clips i don't know [ __ ]
about the ground
awesome episode i know he's got a pretty
wild mustache yeah and he looks a little
bit like the dad
uh george bluth from arrested
development
without with a mustache
we tried to end this a long time ago
yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm very sorry a bonus episode there we
go a little bonus 30 [ __ ] minutes
here we go joints out perfect timing i
lit that when i said let's end it so i
knew it really wasn't gonna end yeah
okay judge judy allen iverson
i should probably
okay
yeah all right leave my comments yeah in
the comments guys oh
i should also let you guys know
as of what two episodes ago
we
are having help with comments now
okay
as of two
i think it's two episodes ago i can't
remember how many episodes
so
my little brother is now hired as our
social media guy for youtube and he's
helping us to comments because we always
say up to a thousand but there's more
there's more than that there's always
gonna be more than that and i just like
i don't want to leave [ __ ] out
so we hire my brother to help us do as
many as possible
okay so just letting you guys know that
[ __ ] in case overflow yeah there's just
too much
so he's now helping us every episode
it's always us on the live chat
yeah we're still gonna it's always gonna
be us still it's my brother
like if he if there's a comment and he's
answering it back he's like i don't know
how to answer this he'll screenshot and
send it to me and go
oh that kid seems sad send him my email
or [ __ ] like that you know if it's like
things as like you can't answer this as
me or marty like you can't be like
thanks thanks for for watching so i
don't want anybody to think about you've
never been you know it's always been us
i'm just saying like so recently now we
have help with comments but it's always
says in the live chat i mean if you
watch i'm at home
i've been with doing the live chat but
just letting you guys know just in case
you think that's weird i want we're
transparent with you guys
we have had what like 40 something or 50
something thousand comments that no no
like 80 000 comments on this channel so
far
we've done them all
all right
as least as many as we press refresh and
that's we've done them all
so we just need some help we really need
some help so me and marty hired my
little brother so just letting you guys
know it might be a little rocco out
there responding to you one of these
days we're gonna hire him for everything
we can yeah ever in life just gonna try
yeah help help marty and i need help so
that's what we're saying tick-tock we
gotta get all that [ __ ] yeah this might
be it we need some [ __ ] help
uh but yeah we just wanna let you guys
know that some of the comments now are
gonna be helped
but we're always there we're always
still there we always read the [ __ ]
we're always going through or liking
commenting just letting us know some of
it is yeah and rocco is one of us i mean
he's a yeah his usual model yeah he's
once he's 18 he might even be a guest on
the show we'll see yeah we talked about
i want him to be 18. he turns 18 next
month so
we'll wait i don't want to bring him
underage here even though i'm not going
to smoke in front of him still i'm not
going to i don't want to no it's weird
to me
uh but not in a bad way just like ah
give me a month yeah we got a lot of
time in the world you'll be 18. um
but yeah guys as one let you know about
that for all the comments for everything
we used to do every comment then it
wasn't a thousand now we're trying to do
more than a thousand
it's never ending guys i don't know what
we'll end up doing but we're always
gonna be here it's always gonna be us
we're always gonna give a [ __ ] so that's
what matters i i'm not gonna say
anything but most podcast people don't
go we need to hire someone to respond to
fans
the overflow because we don't want them
to feel left out all right [ __ ]
we're trying we are really trying we
could just say [ __ ] no and not do it
but that's a point that's the whole
point of the community is to be
together we know some of your
[ __ ] names i i mean if i could
see the live chat i would recognize a
lot more obviously
um there's a lot of evidence all right
so i can't remember all every every eva
and there's like [ __ ] 15 of you guys
so many you guys always comment you guys
have an e with a [ __ ] blue or green
emoji thing and it's like i'm not sure
which one i have to remember the last
names every time uh-huh every time zach
zach sevens zack stevens there's so many
zacks
um guys we're gonna get out of here
thank you so much for being here i'm
sorry i talked your [ __ ] ear off but
that's what happens when i don't smoke
oh gee
i'm like alert
awake
talking i started to sit as um was that
asleep
and now i was like i'm high and alert
that's why someone joins when i'm
falling asleep because it helps
you dead you all good yeah yeah let's go
well guys
thank you so much for being here
thank you for hanging out if you're in
the car be [ __ ] safe if you're on
spotify watching
[ __ ] awesome pretty cool right if
you're on youtube do us that favor leave
a like a comment even if it's just hi
[ __ ] it just say something interact and
the more interaction the more youtube's
like hey
let's suggest this so uh tony hawk not
age restricted nothing my mom not age
range or nothing and the goblin one
surprisingly so thank you guys so much
password episodes are good so
we're trying all right so thank you guys
so much for being here marty you will
not stop rolling these [ __ ] joints
oh we got a whole ad read out of it okay
all right
all right guys thank you so much for
being here this was supposed to be short
we tried to cut it off 35 minutes ago so
i'm very sorry
um
yeah all right this is episode 33.
let's go red city batch
what
you said red titty [ __ ] rant city [ __ ]
red teddy [ __ ]
i was like 33 red titty [ __ ] is this
from a movie and i automatically thought
of total recall or spoiler you're like
mars
three girl boobs 33
all of that happened in that split
second
that was ridiculous um okay yes red city
yes of course i thought you said red
tidy [ __ ]
all right
[ __ ] crazy over there
all right guys thank you so much for
being here from marty o'neil and i i am
thomas dobazilla whatever you want to
call me this has been another podcast
another episode of the dope's usual show
or adobe's usual podcast i should say
and we're here to talk about life
drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between i just got high out of nowhere
from those pants um and everything in
between thank you guys so much for being
here have a dope ass estee
marty
no
no the hash pens while i'm smoking and
these pens
i tried to end this [ __ ] 28
minutes ago
we're like old men fixing a truck we
just kept talking
[Music]